Welcome to your second drink of Moroccan Christmas.
This episode has a little bit of everything.
It has an intervention, a scandalous affair, and Princess Unicorn Dolls.
And we have a lot of fun details.
We reached out to folks from the cast and crew for behind-the-scenes trivia.
Listen to this list.
Justin Spitzer, Aaron Scher, Halstead Sullivan, Jen Salada, Randy Cordray, James Cary,
Stephen Sox and Kate Flannery all shared amazing stuff with us for this episode.
欢迎来到《摩洛哥圣诞节》的第二杯。这一集内容丰富，应有尽有。有干预行动、丑闻恋情，还有独角兽公主娃娃。我们还有很多有趣的细节。我们联系了演职人员，获取了幕后花絮。听听这份名单：贾斯汀·斯皮策、亚伦·谢尔、霍尔斯特德·沙利文、珍·萨拉达、兰迪·科德雷、詹姆斯·卡里、斯蒂芬·索克斯和凯特·弗兰纳里都为这一集分享了精彩的内容。
I mean, we left no rock unturned for this one.
This is true.
So let's dig into the second drink.
A lot of you wrote in about the Princess Unicorn storyline.
And like Jenna said, we have great details about how it all came together.
And Jenna, when we broke down the episode originally, you mentioned there was a commercial
for the doll, but we never played it on the podcast.
We'll shout out to Office Ladies' listener, Sharr T.
我的意思是，为了这一集，我们进行了地毯式的挖掘。这是真的。所以让我们深入探讨第二杯。你们很多人写信询问关于独角兽公主的故事线。就像珍娜说的，我们有关于它是如何成型的精彩细节。珍娜，当我们最初拆解这一集时，你提到有一个关于这个娃娃的广告，但我们从未在播客中播放过。我们要向《办公室女士》的听众 Sharr T. 致敬。
who said, oh, M.G, I found the Princess Unicorn commercial. And she shared the link with us. So I guess
Peacock put it on their official YouTube a few years ago. You got to hear it.
It's Princess Unicorn. Wow. She's Princess Unicorn for tea.
Regal. I love her horn.
You're nice Princess Unicorn. I love you.
On Princess Unicorn, you can depend.
My horn can pierce the sky.
Wow.
她说，天哪，我找到了独角兽公主的广告。她和我们分享了链接。我想几年前 Peacock 把它放在了他们的官方 YouTube 频道上。你一定要听听。是独角兽公主。哇。她是独角兽公主，为了茶会。高贵。我喜欢她的角。你真是个好独角兽公主。我爱你。独角兽公主，你可以信赖。我的角可以刺破天空。哇。
It's amazing.
Royalty with a horn.
Well, Angela, when we first broke down this episode,
you mentioned two things that you could make out
on the dry erase board over in accounting.
But we had a listener that was able to decipher almost the entire board.
It is an amazing list of stuff.
Izzy T from Illinois wrote in,
太棒了。带着角的皇室成员。嗯，安吉拉，当我们第一次拆解这一集时，你提到了你在会计部那边的白板上能看出的两件事。但我们有一位听众能够破译几乎整个白板的内容。这是一份令人惊叹的清单。来自伊利诺伊州的 Izzy T. 写信来，
with this list. And I thought you would enjoy this lady because you love a background catch.
I do. I really do. Izzy said, I looked very intensely at the whiteboard calendar.
That comes up around one minute, 47 seconds. And I think I have found out most of the month's
schedule for December. On the 10th, there is copier machine maintenance at 10 a.m. and an Oxford
rep due at 9 a.m. On the 15th, there is a Christmas party planning committee meeting at 4 p.m. in the conference room.
On the 17th, there is the Scranton C.F.C. annual holiday luncheon at Coopers at 12 a.m.
And Izzy wrote, yes, it really says AM.
On the 18th, there's an accounting staff meeting at 9 a.m.
附上了这份清单。我想你会喜欢这位女士的，因为你喜欢捕捉背景细节。我确实喜欢。我真的非常喜欢。Izzy 说，我非常仔细地看了白板日历。它出现在大约 1 分 47 秒处。我想我已经找出了大部分 12 月的日程安排。10 号，上午 10 点有复印机维护，上午 9 点有牛津代表要来。15 号，下午 4 点在会议室有圣诞派对筹备委员会会议。17 号，中午 12 点在 Coopers 有斯克兰顿 C.F.C. 年度假日午宴。Izzy 写道，是的，它确实写的是上午 12 点。18 号，上午 9 点有会计人员会议。
On the 23rd of December, the warehouse is closed, and it says no shipping until 1226.
Also, on the 24th, it says Christmas Eve office closed at noon.
office Christmas party 1 p.m. On the 25th, it says Merry Christmas. On December 30th, it says
warehouse closed, no shipping until January 2nd. And then on December 31st, it says office closed.
And then for the 31st and the first, it says, happy new year. So much detail. That is amazing
background catchwork, because I remember I tried to zoom in. And I pretty much the thing that stood out
to me was that the Christmas party was on Christmas Eve, which I thought was hilarious.
Also, a lot of people wrote in about the Angel and Phyllis Party Planning Committee power
12 月 23 号，仓库关闭，上面写着 12 月 26 号前不发货。此外，24 号写着平安夜办公室中午关闭，办公室圣诞派对下午 1 点。25 号写着圣诞快乐。12 月 30 号写着仓库关闭，1 月 2 号前不发货。然后 31 号写着办公室关闭。对于 31 号和 1 号，写着新年快乐。细节太多了。那是令人惊叹的背景捕捉工作，因为我记得我试着放大看。对我来说最突出的就是圣诞派对是在平安夜举行的，我觉得这太搞笑了。此外，很多人写信询问关于安吉拉和菲利斯的派对筹备委员会权力
struggle. Elise M. from Pennsylvania says, I absolutely love the scenes between Angela and Phyllis.
They are hilarious. They make me laugh every time I watch this episode. How did you all stop
from completely cracking up? Well, Elise, it was really difficult not to laugh, and we did laugh a ton.
But just for fun, I wanted to see if there were any extra bits between me and Phyllis,
and I found in the Candybag alts all of these Phyllis talking head alts, they are so hilarious
and I wanted to read you one, okay?
Yes, yes.
It's an alt about how she's kind of flexing that she's planning this Christmas party herself.
斗争。来自宾夕法尼亚州的 Elise M. 说，我绝对喜欢安吉拉和菲利斯之间的场景。她们太搞笑了。每次看这一集我都笑得不行。你们是怎么忍住不笑场的？嗯，Elise，不笑真的很难，我们确实笑了很多次。但为了好玩，我想看看我和菲利斯之间是否还有额外的片段，我在糖果袋的备选台词里发现了所有这些菲利斯的独白备选，它们太搞笑了，我想读给你听一个，好吗？好的，好的。这是一个关于她有点炫耀自己独自筹划这个圣诞派对的备选台词。
Okay, ready?
Yes.
Phyllis.
The Christmas party I organized this year is going to be our best one yet.
I'm really good at this.
I'm considering starting a party planning business on the side.
I'd call it a touch of Phyllis because everything's a little sweeter with a touch of Phyllis.
And then she takes out a notepad and says, ooh, that's good.
好了，准备好了吗？好的。菲利斯：我今年组织的圣诞派对将是我们有史以来最好的一次。我真的很擅长这个。我正在考虑副业开一家派对策划公司。我会叫它“菲利斯的触碰”，因为有了“菲利斯的触碰”，一切都会变得更甜美一点。然后她拿出一个记事本说，噢，那太棒了。
I can see that on a bench somewhere.
I love it, a touch of Phyllis.
Well, lastly, we got a fan mail flurry.
Samantha H, Debbie R, Nathan S, Michaela N, Allison D, McKenzie P., and Tamara L.
all rode in because of a little bit of banter you and I had.
Angela, I asked you why the character of Angela Martin was always so angry at Christmas.
And Angie you said that there are levels to Angela Martin's anger, but that the, quote,
Christmas bitch is a whole other level of bitch.
我能想象它出现在某个长椅上。我喜欢它，“菲利斯的触碰”。最后，我们收到了一阵粉丝邮件。Samantha H.、Debbie R.、Nathan S.、Michaela N.、Allison D.、McKenzie P. 和 Tamara L. 都写信来，因为你和我之间的一点玩笑。安吉拉，我问你为什么安吉拉·马丁这个角色在圣诞节总是那么生气。安吉拉，你说安吉拉·马丁的愤怒是有等级的，但所谓的“圣诞婊子”是另一个层面的婊子。
Well, we got several messages, like I said, a fan mail flurry of people saying,
please make Christmas bitch into a sweater.
Another one said, quote, I really feel like Christmas bitch needs to be on some seasonal
merch.
Just really cracked me up.
Oh, Christmas
bitch is really fun.
I totally forgot about that.
嗯，我们收到了几条信息，就像我说的，一阵粉丝邮件，人们说，请把“圣诞婊子”做成毛衣。另一位说，引用一下，“我真的觉得‘圣诞婊子’需要出现在一些季节性商品上。”真的让我笑死了。噢，“圣诞婊子”真的很有趣。我完全忘了那件事了。
Now you guys all have my wheels turn in.
All right, well, that was really fun.
Thanks to everyone who wrote in.
And please go to OfficeLadies.com to submit your favorite second drink moments,
and we'll share them on the podcast.
And now here's our second drink of Moroccan Christmas.
I'm Jenna Fisher.
And I'm Angela Kinsey.
现在你们让我的脑子转起来了。好吧，那真的很有趣。感谢所有写信来的人。请访问 OfficeLadies.com 提交你最喜欢的“第二杯”时刻，我们会在播客中分享它们。现在这是我们的《摩洛哥圣诞节》第二杯。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。
We were on the office together.
And we're best friends.
And now we're doing.
the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you.
Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories
that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the office ladies.
I hope you're in a festive mood today because we're talking about Moroccan Christmas.
我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你做终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将拆解《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。希望你今天心情愉快，因为我们要谈论《摩洛哥圣诞节》。
So get out your Christmas plaid, but put away that nativity scene because Phyllis is going to
throw you the party of a lifetime.
She sure is.
It's Season 5, Episode 11, written by Justin Spitzer, and directed.
by Paul Figue. Here is your summary. As you said, Phyllis throws a Moroccan-themed Christmas party,
which receives compliments from the majority of the group, but some serious contempt from Angela.
Oh, she is not happy. Dwight runs a black market doll trade out of the office,
and Meredith gets wasted and sets herself on fire. That's a doozy of a sentence.
所以拿出你的圣诞格子呢，但收起那个耶稣诞生场景，因为菲利斯要为你举办一场终身难忘的派对。她确实会。这是第五季第 11 集，由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，保罗·费格执导。这是你的摘要。正如你所说，菲利斯举办了一个摩洛哥主题的圣诞派对，这得到了大多数人的称赞，但遭到了安吉拉的严重蔑视。噢，她很不高兴。德怀特在办公室里经营黑市娃娃交易，而梅雷迪思喝醉了并把自己点着了。那真是一个惊人的句子。
It's quite a work party.
Michael decides to hold an intervention demanding Meredith get help for her alcoholism, and then talk about a doozy of a work party.
Phyllis spills the beans about Angela and Dwight in front of everyone.
Everyone.
She announces it to the whole bullpen.
Except Andy.
Oh, Andy.
Yeah.
这真是一场工作派对。迈克尔决定进行干预，要求梅雷迪思为她的酗酒寻求帮助，然后谈谈一场惊人的工作派对。菲利斯在所有人面前泄露了关于安吉拉和德怀特的事。所有人。她向整个办公室宣布了这件事。除了安迪。噢，安迪。是的。
Andy and his sitar.
His goodbye as he's leaving broke my heart.
We're getting ahead.
All right.
Fast fact number one, this was the third Christmas-themed episode of The Office.
Yes, it was.
安迪和他的西塔琴。他离开时的告别让我心碎。我们超前了。我们超前了。我们超前了。好吧。速记事实第一条，这是《办公室》的第三个圣诞主题剧集。是的，它是。
Season five, but only three Christmas episodes. Why?
Well, the first season, we didn't have one.
Mm-hmm.
And then in season four, it was the writer's strike.
I know.
We missed a Christmas party.
It has been two years since we had a Christmas party on the office.
They were always some of my favorite episodes, so I was excited.
第五季，但只有三个圣诞剧集。为什么？嗯，第一季，我们没有。嗯哼。然后在第四季，是编剧大罢工。我知道。我们错过了一个圣诞派对。距离我们在《办公室》举办圣诞派对已经过去两年了。它们一直是我最喜欢的剧集之一，所以我很兴奋。
Me too.
I liked him because they were majority group scenes.
Yes.
We were all together all the time.
It was like a whole episode of conference room.
So lots of bits, lots of laughing.
We would just have the best time.
We would get loopy.
我也是。我喜欢它们是因为它们大多是集体场景。是的。我们一直都在一起。就像整集都在会议室里。所以有很多片段，很多笑声。我们总是玩得很开心。我们会变得很疯。
We would.
But in the best way.
Fast fact number two, the inspiration for this episode, I was able to get in touch with writer Justin Spitzer.
What Justin have to say?
He told me that they had had these two ideas rolling around.
for a really long time. The first one was the idea of a Moroccan Christmas. They just loved the idea
that Phyllis had thrown that amazing goodbye party for Toby and that maybe the success had gone to her
head a little bit. And she's going to go big. Big theme. Yes. They loved that this would piss Angela off.
我们会。但以最好的方式。速记事实第二条，这一集的灵感，我联系到了编剧贾斯汀·斯皮策。贾斯汀怎么说？他告诉我，他们有两个想法在脑海中盘旋了很长时间。第一个是摩洛哥圣诞节的想法。他们只是喜欢菲利斯为托比举办了那场精彩的告别派对，也许成功让她有点冲昏了头脑。她要搞大的。大主题。是的。他们喜欢这会让安吉拉生气。
Mm-hmm. So this was like one card, right? You know what the card probably said?
What? Phyllis happy, Angela pissed.
Christmas, question mark.
Why is your character always so angry on Christmas?
She's angry all the time.
But it really comes out at the holidays.
I tell you, she has levels of anger.
Sometimes she's like, suspicious bitch.
嗯哼。所以这就像一张卡片，对吧？你知道卡片上可能写了什么吗？什么？菲利斯开心，安吉拉生气。圣诞节，问号。为什么你的角色在圣诞节总是那么生气？她一直都很生气。但它在假期里表现得特别明显。我告诉你，她的愤怒是有等级的。有时她是“多疑婊子”。
Sometimes she's happy bitch.
Sometimes she's sad bitch.
Hmm.
And then Christmas bitch is a whole different bitch.
Oh boy.
Buckle in for Christmas bitch.
Okay, so the other card that they had on the wall for a really long time said Meredith Intervention.
Oh, okay.
有时她是“快乐婊子”。有时她是“悲伤婊子”。嗯。然后“圣诞婊子”是完全不同的婊子。噢，天哪。系好安全带迎接“圣诞婊子”。好吧，所以他们在墙上贴了很长时间的另一张卡片写着“梅雷迪思干预”。噢，好的。
So they decided to marry these two ideas. Remember when they did like, Michael has to fire someone on Halloween while we're all dressed up?
Yeah, it's the same thing. Yes, exactly. Justin said that a holiday party also seemed like a really good place for Meredith to drink too much and set her hair on fire. Like there could be this sort of rock bottomy moment.
Right. And it's an event. It's like a big event and everyone's there to witness it.
Yes. Fast fact number three, I have a talking hair.
head observation for this episode. Oh, I'm so curious. So as you re-watch this episode,
take a note of the talking heads. Almost all of them are filmed from different angles than we
normally would. I believe there's only one where someone's seated in the traditional chair
with the kind of party through the blind. Right. Right. We're all over the office. All over the
所以他们决定把这两个想法结合起来。还记得他们做过像迈克尔必须在万圣节解雇某人，而我们都盛装打扮吗？是的，是一回事。是的，完全正确。贾斯汀说，节日派对似乎也是梅雷迪思喝太多酒并烧着头发的好地方。就像可能会有这种跌入谷底的时刻。对。这是一个活动。就像一个大活动，每个人都在场见证。是的。速记事实第三条，我有一个关于这一集的独白观察。噢，我太好奇了。所以当你重温这一集时，注意一下独白。几乎所有拍摄的角度都与我们平时不同。我相信只有一个人坐在传统的椅子上，透过百叶窗。对。对。我们在办公室各处。在办公室各处。
office. So this was not just because there was a party happening behind us. Justin said this was because
they wanted to wait until they were in the editing room to place the talking heads throughout the
episode. And they didn't want anything in the background to like in some way mess up their ability
to move these talking heads around. Well, they had probably learned their lesson from that episode,
weight loss. Yeah. Where they had to digitally, it's hard word to say.
They had to digitally change Ed's tie and shirt because they kept moving the talking heads
and what was happening behind him didn't match.
Yeah, so you'll notice even Michael's talking heads, he is not seated at his desk.
所以这不仅仅是因为我们身后有派对。贾斯汀说这是因为他们想等到剪辑室里再把独白放在整集中。他们不希望背景中的任何东西以某种方式搞砸他们移动这些独白的能力。嗯，他们可能从那一集“减肥”中吸取了教训。是的。他们不得不数字化，这是一个很难说的词。他们不得不数字化改变埃德的领带和衬衫，因为他们一直在移动独白，而他身后发生的事情不匹配。是的，所以你会注意到即使是迈克尔的独白，他也没有坐在办公桌前。
He's standing in front of his desk and they purposely framed out the window behind him
because timing-wise, they didn't know if it would be like still daytime or if it would be evening.
So they really tried to make all the talking heads as totally neutral as possible.
Smart. Yeah, and it was kind of fun. After Justin told me that, I went back and rewatch the episode, and it was totally true.
Yeah. I read the shooting draft, and definitely things are moved all around. So it's good they did it. Yeah.
That's all I got. Well, before we get into this episode, I went digging in my digital clutter.
Okay. And I found an email from Paul Feig that on December 11, 2008, he emailed the group, Jenna, and invited us all.
to a Christmas taco party to watch the Moroccan Christmas episode at his house.
他站在办公桌前，他们特意把身后的窗户框了出去，因为从时间上讲，他们不知道是白天还是晚上。所以他们真的试图让所有的独白尽可能中性。聪明。是的，这很有趣。贾斯汀告诉我之后，我回去重看了这一集，这完全是真的。是的。我读了拍摄草稿，事情确实到处都在移动。所以他们这样做很好。是的。这就是我所有的了。嗯，在进入这一集之前，我翻了翻我的数字杂物。好的。我发现保罗·费格在 2008 年 12 月 11 日发给团队的一封电子邮件，珍娜，他邀请我们所有人。去参加一个圣诞塔可派对，在他家观看《摩洛哥圣诞节》这一集。
Oh.
And he said, I know, I know, Morocco and tacos make no sense, except they do kind of rhyme,
and we have a really great taco cart that we want to use.
And we all went over to his house December 11, 2008, and watched Moroccan Christmas together.
Aw, I love that you brought that up because Paul and Lori Figg used to host so many viewing parties
at their house, and they were just the most wonderful hosts. And I'll never forget, he had that screen
that could come down from the ceiling. So he had like a very normal-looking living room.
Yeah. Cozy, like a place you'd read books. I believe there was like a green leather chair.
噢。他说，我知道，我知道，摩洛哥和塔可毫无意义，除非它们有点押韵，而且我们有一个非常棒的塔可车想用。我们都在 2008 年 12 月 11 日去了他家，一起看了《摩洛哥圣诞节》。噢，我喜欢你提到这一点，因为保罗和洛里·费格过去常在他们家举办很多观看派对，他们是最好的主人。我永远不会忘记，他有那个可以从天花板上下来的屏幕。所以他有一个看起来很正常的客厅。是的。舒适，就像你读书的地方。我相信有一把绿色皮椅。
Oh yeah, there was like cozy chairs with like a blanket draped over it. So cozy. And then all of a sudden
when it was time to watch the show, the screen would come down out of the ceiling and it would turn
into this amazing viewing experience. I thought these guys are doing it right. They know what they're doing.
Yeah. And they have a great taco cart. Oh, that's so cool. Well, there you go. Just a little something from my digital clutter.
And now we should break down this episode. Well, I think we should take a break first. And now we should take a break.
Let's do it. And we'll be back to talk all things, Moroccan Christmas.
The Second World War is the largest event in human history. A 20-part series.
with Tom Hanks.
噢，是的，有舒适的椅子，上面披着毯子。太舒适了。然后突然当该看节目时，屏幕会从天花板上下来，它会变成这种惊人的观看体验。我想这些人做对了。他们知道自己在做什么。是的。而且他们有一个很棒的塔可车。噢，太酷了。好吧，给你。只是我数字杂物里的一点东西。现在我们应该拆解这一集。嗯，我想我们应该先休息一下。现在我们应该休息一下。让我们做吧。我们会回来谈论关于《摩洛哥圣诞节》的一切。第二次世界大战是人类历史上最大的事件。一个 20 部分的系列。由汤姆·汉克斯主持。
No part of the globe was untouched.
No life unchanged.
Experience the ultimate account of World War II.
Every single person had a story.
These are the stories that make us who we are.
Listen to World War II with Tom Hanks on Apple, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Well, we are back, and, um, wow, is Dwight's desk festive or what?
Oh my.
全球没有一个地方未受影响。没有一个生命未被改变。体验关于二战的终极叙述。每个人都有一个故事。这些故事造就了我们。在 Apple、Spotify 或任何你获取播客的地方收听汤姆·汉克斯的《第二次世界大战》。嗯，我们回来了，嗯，哇，德怀特的办公桌很喜庆，不是吗？噢，天哪。
an epic prank by Jim. Every single thing on Dwight's desk is wrapped in Christmas wrapping paper.
Including his chair. Yeah. When did Jim do this? How long did it take? What the heck?
I have so much to share about this. Oh, go. All right. First of all, Justin Spitzer told me this was his
idea. This was his pitch. He said that he was always talking to his friends who worked in the
corporate world and he would ask them what sort of pranks go on in your office? Because I think at a certain point,
started to stress out the writers that they had to come up with these Jim Dwight pranks.
Mm-hmm.
So they were always fishing.
吉姆的一个史诗般的恶作剧。德怀特办公桌上的每一件东西都用圣诞包装纸包着。包括他的椅子。是的。吉姆是什么时候做这个的？花了多长时间？到底怎么回事？我有很多要分享的。噢，去吧。好吧。首先，贾斯汀·斯皮策告诉我这是他的主意。这是他的推销。他说他总是和在企业界工作的朋友交谈，他会问他们，你们办公室里有什么样的恶作剧？因为我认为在某个时候，编剧们必须想出这些吉姆和德怀特的恶作剧，这让他们感到压力。嗯哼。所以他们一直在寻找。
Tell me a prank.
I need an office prank.
He said that the single most-mentioned prank was this idea of wrapping someone's desk in paper or aluminum foil.
Mm-hmm.
So Justin pitched this idea.
We got so much mail from people asking, how did we pull this off?
I reached out to Randy Cordray.
Oh, Randy.
告诉我一个恶作剧。我需要一个办公室恶作剧。他说被提到最多的恶作剧就是把某人的办公桌用纸或铝箔包起来的想法。嗯哼。所以贾斯汀提出了这个想法。我们收到了很多邮件，人们问，我们是怎么做到的？我联系了兰迪·科德雷。噢，兰迪。
He shared all the details.
Of course he did.
he probably did a deep dive for you on something random.
He did.
All those things.
Okay.
So, first of all, he said there was a note in the script that did not make it into the episode,
and it was a Jim talking head, and here's how it went.
他分享了所有细节。他当然会。他可能为你深入挖掘了一些随机的事情。他做了。所有那些事情。好吧。所以，首先，他说剧本里有一个没有进入这一集的注释，那是一个吉姆的独白，它是这样进行的。
Jim says, actually, it took me about a week to recreate the desk and chair in chicken wire.
I had to come in about four hours early and set it all up,
and I think I pulled something in my back dragging Dwight's real desk all.
the way up to the roof, all for a three-second payoff. Totally worth it. I read that too, and I was like,
why do you have to take the desk up to the roof? Why couldn't you just stash it in the warehouse?
I swear I remember us filming a tag of Dwight working up on the roof. Oh my gosh. I swear we did.
I can't confirm it, but I feel like I remember what, you know, you're walking from your trailer to
hair and makeup and you're like, why are they putting a desk on the roof?
吉姆说，实际上，我花了一个星期用铁丝网重建了办公桌和椅子。我不得不提前四个小时来设置这一切，我想我在把德怀特的真桌子拖到屋顶时拉伤了背部。所有这些只是为了三秒钟的回报。完全值得。我也读到了那个，我就想，为什么你必须把桌子带到屋顶？为什么你不能把它藏在仓库里？我发誓我记得我们拍摄了一个德怀特在屋顶工作的标签。噢，天哪。我发誓我们做了。我无法证实，但我觉得我记得，你知道，你从拖车走到化妆间，然后你说，为什么他们要把桌子放在屋顶上？
I have a hazy memory of this.
What else did Randy say?
All right.
So Randy also said that Greg Daniels was pretty insistent that the gag desk be made out of chicken wire because that's what it said in the script.
Oh, and he wanted it exactly like that.
Yeah, because we'd sort of, Jim has this whole speech.
He's like, it needs to reflect with Jim said.
But chicken wire is stronger than you think.
我对这个有模糊的记忆。兰迪还说了什么？好吧。所以兰迪还说格雷格·丹尼尔斯非常坚持恶作剧桌子必须用铁丝网做，因为剧本上就是这么写的。噢，他想要完全那样。是的，因为我们，吉姆有整段演讲。他说，它需要反映吉姆所说的。但铁丝网比你想象的要强。
Oh, yes, it is.
Right?
It wouldn't have collapsed.
Nope.
It wouldn't have, Ange.
Did they make one with chicken wire and it didn't work?
Yes.
Oh, my gosh.
噢，是的，它是。对吧？它不会倒塌的。不。它不会的，安吉。他们做了一个用铁丝网的，但没成功吗？是的。噢，天哪。
So Randy said that he and Paul Figue and our set designer Michael Gallenberg and our first AD Kelly Cantley all tried to talk Greg out of this.
They were very skeptical it would work.
But Greg really needed to see it for himself.
Okay.
So here's what they did.
They built four different desks out of four different materials.
Oh, my gosh.
What were the materials?
所以兰迪说他和保罗·费格、我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格和我们的第一副导演凯利·坎特利都试图劝阻格雷格。他们非常怀疑它是否有效。但格雷格真的需要亲眼看看。好吧。所以这就是他们做的。他们用四种不同的材料建造了四种不同的桌子。噢，天哪。材料是什么？
One of them was chicken wire.
Okay.
One was styrofoam.
Ooh.
One was balsa wood.
What?
And one was corrugated cardboard.
And then they meticulously gift-wrapped all of them.
其中一个是铁丝网。好的。一个是泡沫塑料。噢。一个是轻木。什么？一个是瓦楞纸板。然后他们一丝不苟地把它们全部包装好。
Oh, oh.
Can I guess which one worked the best?
Yeah.
What do you guys think?
I wish we could hear what you think out there.
I think the cardboard.
The corrugated cardboard.
That's what I would bet on.
噢，噢。我可以猜猜哪一个效果最好吗？是的。你们觉得呢？我希望我们能听到你们的想法。我觉得是纸板。瓦楞纸板。那是我会押注的。
All right.
At the end, I'll tell you which one it was.
Okay.
Okay. So they set up one of the desks. Yeah. And then they asked our stand-in, Stephen Sox, to come in and do Dwight's motion of walking in, setting the briefcase down and sitting down to see what would happen.
Now, there's four different types of desks and four different types of chairs. Yes. Wow. And Stephen is going to try each one while all these people watch him. Oh my gosh. Would you do at work today, hon? Well, I sat on a faky desk made out of course.
Christmas wrapping. I have to say, I was fascinated by the backstory of this, because as actors,
we just showed up, there was a wrapped desk, we did the scene. Wow. Wow. Yeah. This was like,
好吧。最后，我会告诉你它是哪一个。好的。好的。好的。所以他们设置了其中一张桌子。是的。然后他们要求我们的替身斯蒂芬·索克斯进来，做德怀特走进来、放下公文包并坐下的动作，看看会发生什么。现在，有四种不同类型的桌子和四种不同类型的椅子。是的。哇。斯蒂芬要尝试每一个，而所有这些人都在看着他。噢，天哪。亲爱的，你今天在工作做了什么？嗯，我坐在了一张用圣诞包装纸做的假桌子上。我必须说，我对这个的幕后故事很着迷，因为作为演员，我们只是出现，有一张包装好的桌子，我们拍了那场戏。哇。哇。是的。这就像，
look at all the prep that went into this one little bit. Oh, my gosh. Also, I was so fascinated by
this idea of being a tester that I reached out to Stephen Sox to ask him, what was this day like for
you? And lady, he sent in an audio clip. Oh my God, amazing. We have to hear it. Okay, play it.
I've vividly remembered this test.
I didn't do a lot of tests like this, so it really stands out.
I think we were all excited to see this cold open come to be
because it read so funny in the script,
but I think we have to remember the pressure that you have
看看为这一个小片段所做的所有准备。噢，天哪。此外，我对成为测试员的想法非常着迷，以至于我联系了斯蒂芬·索克斯问他，这一天对你来说是什么样的？女士，他发来了一个音频片段。噢，我的天，太棒了。我们必须听听。好的，播放它。我生动地记得这个测试。我没有做过很多这样的测试，所以它真的很突出。我想我们都很兴奋看到这个冷开场成为现实，因为它在剧本里读起来很有趣，但我认为我们必须记住你面临的压力
trying to make something like this a reality.
You know, the whole idea probably seemed kind of easy on paper,
but it was really up to the set designer Michael Gallenberg
and his team to make it a reality.
Like I said, I would do tests.
but they were mainly hair and makeup tests or, you know, a lot of camera tests, but I don't remember
one quite like this. So I walk into the bullpen and there's a lot of people there.
Greg Daniels was there, the director Paul Feig, Randy Cordray, our first assistant director,
试图让这样的事情成为现实。你知道，整个想法在纸面上看起来可能很容易，但真正让布景设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格和他的团队实现它是他们的责任。就像我说的，我会做测试。但它们主要是发型和化妆测试，或者，你知道，很多摄像机测试，但我记不起像这样的测试了。所以我走进办公室，那里有很多人。格雷格·丹尼尔斯在那里，导演保罗·费格，兰迪·科德雷，我们的第一副导演，
Kelly Cantley, of course, Michael Gallenberg, and then Phil Shea and the prop department as well.
And what I saw was just like what you see in the episode, it just looked like a desk
wrapped in wrapping paper. But as soon as I walked in,
It was made clear to me that I should not touch the desk.
Like, don't really go near the desk until we're going to do the test.
I mean, specific instructions.
And it was told to everybody that to just keep clear the desk, don't touch this thing.
It was their only prototype.
凯利·坎特利，当然，迈克尔·加伦伯格，还有菲尔·谢和道具部门。我看到的就是你在剧集中看到的，它看起来就像一张用包装纸包着的桌子。但当我一走进去，我就被明确告知不要碰桌子。我的意思是，在我们要进行测试之前，不要靠近桌子。我的意思是，具体的指示。每个人都被告知要远离桌子，不要碰这个东西。这是他们唯一的原型。
And so I kind of imagined underneath the wrapping paper, like it was some kind of house
of cards or something, just ready to fall.
So I didn't even want to, like, breathe on it.
Because I just was thinking in my mind, what if I knocked this thing over?
in front of everybody before we even do the test.
I mean, that would be like a total nightmare.
But then they were ready to do it, and the props department gave me the briefcase,
which had something inside of it, you know, to give it some weight.
所以我有点想象在包装纸下面，就像某种纸牌屋之类的，随时准备倒塌。所以我甚至不想，像，对着它呼吸。因为我脑子里一直在想，如果我把这东西撞倒了怎么办？在所有人面前，在我们甚至做测试之前。我的意思是，那将是一场彻底的噩梦。但后来他们准备好了，道具部门给了我公文包，里面装了东西，你知道，给它一点重量。
And so they said, go.
So I threw the briefcase on the desk, sat in the chair, and I totally expected that I would
fall like right to the ground.
But to be honest, the chair felt kind of like a regular office chair, maybe like an old
office chair that kind of semi reclined and collapsed a little, but it still was fully supporting
me. And the desk just kind of bent a little bit. It looked like a saggy, like rope bridge or something
with the briefcase on top of it. But obviously there was major disappointment in the room.
I mean, just everyone looked at it with just such disappointment. And the air just kind of like left
所以他们说，开始。所以我把公文包扔在桌子上，坐在椅子上，我完全预料到我会直接摔到地上。但老实说，椅子感觉就像一把普通的办公椅，也许像一把旧办公椅，有点半躺和塌陷，但它仍然完全支撑着我。桌子只是有点弯曲。它看起来像一个下垂的，像绳桥之类的东西，上面放着公文包。但显然房间里有巨大的失望。我的意思是，每个人看着它都带着如此失望。空气就像从
the room. And being the only one there that didn't really know it was everything that was going on,
I kind of felt like I had messed up or something.
So it was very awkward moment.
So I got up off the chair and I remember standing next to Michael Gallenberg and kind of put
in my hand to my chin and looking at the props that didn't work and just kind of, oh, that didn't work.
Oh, that's too bad.
You know, like kind of try to fit in.
And so it was very memorable moment.
房间里离开了。作为唯一一个不知道发生了什么的人，我感觉我搞砸了什么。所以这是一个非常尴尬的时刻。所以我从椅子上站起来，我记得站在迈克尔·加伦伯格旁边，把手放在下巴上，看着没成功的道具，只是有点，噢，那没成功。噢，太糟糕了。你知道，就像试图融入其中。所以这是一个非常难忘的时刻。
But then they brought another desk out, like a few minutes later, they had everyone leave
so they could reset.
And this one is the one that worked.
It's the prototype that ended up making it as the final one.
And it just collapsed.
I mean, I hit the ground pretty hard.
And it kind of surprised me because of the first one and how it was made.
But it was pretty memorable.
但后来他们几分钟后又拿出了另一张桌子，他们让每个人离开以便重置。这一张是成功的。它是最终成为最终版本的原型。它只是倒塌了。我的意思是，我重重地摔在地上。它让我有点惊讶，因为第一个和它是怎么做的。但这很令人难忘。
Isn't that such a fascinating, like, look into behind the scenes of making a show?
Yeah.
I mean, we obviously weren't.
weren't there that day, right?
Right.
So we had no idea all of these desks being made and all of these like test runs and Stephen, oh my gosh.
So Randy said that the desk that worked was made out of styrofoam.
Oh, dang it.
这不是一个关于制作节目的幕后观察吗？是的。我的意思是，我们显然不在那里。那天，对吧？对。所以我们不知道所有这些桌子被制作出来，所有这些测试运行，还有斯蒂芬，噢，天哪。所以兰迪说成功的桌子是用泡沫塑料做的。噢，该死。
But here's the thing.
It sounds like they only did two tests.
They did chicken wire didn't work.
They did styrofoam.
It worked.
So they stopped.
Yeah.
So lady, maybe the corrugated cardboard.
但问题是。听起来他们只做了两次测试。他们做了铁丝网，没成功。他们做了泡沫塑料。它成功了。所以他们停下来了。是的。所以女士，也许瓦楞纸板。
would have worked. We don't know. Okay. Okay. You could be right. It could be right. But boy,
the styrofoam, man, it went down. And then finally, Randy told me when it was time to shoot,
they made three desks out of the styrofoam that they had ready to go, but that rain nailed it on
the first take, so we didn't even need any of the other backups. It was a one taker. It's amazing.
Well, Phil Shea was really busy this episode. He had to make so many props. The desk obviously was the
biggest one. Oh, yeah. But we have more to share. Princess Unicorn. Princess Unicorn, but there's more.
Oh, what else? Oh, you've got a whole thing. I've got some stuff. Oh, good stuff. All right, let's get into the episode. All that was just the cold open.
I know. Well, the episode starts with you really are getting a view of the bullpen and how it's decorated.
会成功的。我们不知道。好的。好的。你可能是对的。可能是对的。但天哪，泡沫塑料，伙计，它倒下了。最后，兰迪告诉我，当该拍摄时，他们用他们准备好的泡沫塑料做了三张桌子，但兰迪在第一次拍摄时就搞定了，所以我们甚至不需要任何其他备份。这是一次过。太棒了。嗯，菲尔·谢在这一集里真的很忙。他不得不制作这么多道具。桌子显然是最大的一个。噢，是的。但我们还有更多要分享。独角兽公主。独角兽公主，但还有更多。噢，还有什么？噢，你有一整件事。我有一些东西。噢，好东西。好吧，让我们进入这一集。所有这些只是冷开场。我知道。嗯，这一集开始时你真的看到了办公室，以及它是如何装饰的。
Phyllis is going around and sort of doing last touches, right? Yes. Where did the budget for this come from? I say she dug into some
Bob Vance Cash, because this is an over-the-top party.
Oh, that is such a good point, Angela.
Well, she has a talking head that she says the theme for her Christmas party is called
Nights in Morocco.
I love a party with a theme.
I know.
I get really excited.
菲利斯四处走动，做最后的润色，对吧？是的。这笔预算是从哪里来的？我说她挖了一些鲍勃·万斯的现金，因为这是一个过度的派对。噢，那是一个很好的观点，安吉拉。嗯，她有一个独白，她说她的圣诞派对主题叫“摩洛哥之夜”。我喜欢有主题的派对。我知道。我真的很兴奋。
I mean, my 50th birthday, my theme was hummingbirds, and we all painted hummingbirds,
and I had little pink hummingbirds like garland hanging in the bushes.
It was amazing.
I love a theme.
Well, Phyllis does too.
And did you notice that Phyllis has on brand new glasses for this episode?
No.
Yes.
我的意思是，我 50 岁生日，我的主题是蜂鸟，我们都画了蜂鸟，我在灌木丛中挂了粉红色的小蜂鸟花环。太棒了。我喜欢主题。嗯，菲利斯也喜欢。你注意到菲利斯在这一集里戴了全新的眼镜吗？没有。是的。
And we talked about it in the DVD commentary.
And Kate said,
Ange, do you remember they were called her power glasses?
What?
I know.
And because Phyllis is like the head of the PPC,
she's like a boss lady,
they wanted her look to reflect that.
我们在 DVD 评论中谈到了它。凯特说，安吉，你记得它们被称为她的“权力眼镜”吗？什么？我知道。因为菲利斯就像 PPC 的负责人，她就像一个女老板，他们希望她的外表能反映这一点。
Oh, I love this detail.
Yes.
And Phil Shea brought a bunch of glasses to Phyllis.
They picked out this particular.
pair, and they even put her prescription in them. So Phyllis and her power glasses are going to take
Angela to task. Well, her standoff with Angela starts right away. She marches over to Angela's desk,
and she just zeroes right in on that nativity scene. Yeah. And she, like, just sweeps half of it into the
drawer. Baby Jesus went into the drawer. Sure did. Angela's not happy. I have a background catch
噢，我喜欢这个细节。是的。菲尔·谢给菲利斯带了一堆眼镜。他们挑选了这一副，他们甚至把她的处方放进去了。所以菲利斯和她的权力眼镜要给安吉拉布置任务。嗯，她和安吉拉的对峙马上就开始了。她走到安吉拉的桌子前，她直接盯着那个耶稣诞生场景。是的。她，就像，把一半扫进了抽屉。小耶稣进了抽屉。确实。安吉拉很不高兴。我有一个背景捕捉
at one minute, 50 seconds. Did you see what was on the dry erase board?
It was fuzzy.
Okay, well, I zoomed in on it, and this was so fascinating to me.
On the calendar, it says December 10th, copier maintenance.
Which just made me laugh so hard because the office got new chairs, but that same old copier still there.
And then it said on December 23rd, the warehouse is closed, and at noon on December 24th, Dunder Mifflin closes, and the party starts at 1.
So we're having a party on Christmas Eve at 1 o'clock?
That's what it said on the dry erase board.
在 1 分 50 秒。你看到白板上有什么了吗？它是模糊的。好的，嗯，我放大了它，这对我来说太迷人了。在日历上，写着 12 月 10 日，复印机维护。这让我笑得太厉害了，因为办公室买了新椅子，但那台旧复印机还在那里。然后它说在 12 月 23 日，仓库关闭，在 12 月 24 日中午，邓德·米夫林关闭，派对在 1 点开始。所以我们在平安夜下午 1 点举行派对？白板上就是这么写的。
So I was like, what the heck?
Everyone's there on Christmas Eve.
So later in the episode, when Michael is dragging Meredith into a rehab center, it's Christmas
Eve.
According to the dry erase board.
I don't know if that's what the writers intended, but that really got me tickled.
And I have a bone to pick with Phyllis.
Oh.
所以我当时想，到底怎么回事？每个人都在平安夜。所以后来在这一集里，当迈克尔把梅雷迪思拖进康复中心时，是平安夜。根据白板。我不知道这是不是编剧的意图，但这真的让我觉得很有趣。而且我对菲利斯有意见。噢。
Because Phyllis says that.
Angela's nativity scene is not on theme. It's not Knights of Morocco. Right? Well, what about the fact that Michael
has on his Christmas tie that he has worn every single Christmas, right? Pam has on a pin on her sweater of Santa.
Oh. Phyllis has a little wreath on her jacket. So I feel like Phyllis is singling Angela out.
I think all that evidence is really good. I also think it's really obvious that she's singling Angela out. I think the entire party was thrown to piss off Angela. I know. I know. And then these little details, I guess, are just little jabs. Little digs. I mean, she makes Angela get rid of the Christmas tree. Oh, lady. All right. I have to share about this because in the episode, it's like three seconds, right? Yeah. This was a huge.
huge scene. This was like multiple location scenes, you guys. It took like a half of a day.
What? Yes. In the script, and we actually did film this, and it's in deleted scenes,
Angela Martin goes over to the tree. It's double her size, and she has to drag it through the bullpen.
因为菲利斯说。安吉拉的耶稣诞生场景不在主题上。不是摩洛哥之夜。对吧？嗯，迈克尔戴着他每个圣诞节都戴的圣诞领带，这怎么说？帕姆的毛衣上有一个圣诞老人的别针。噢。菲利斯的夹克上有一个小花环。所以我感觉菲利斯在针对安吉拉。我觉得所有这些证据都很好。我也觉得很明显她在针对安吉拉。我觉得整个派对就是为了惹恼安吉拉而举办的。我知道。我知道。然后这些小细节，我想，只是小刺。小挖苦。我的意思是，她让安吉拉处理掉圣诞树。噢，女士。好吧。我必须分享这个，因为在这一集中，它就像三秒钟，对吧？是的。这是一个巨大的。巨大的场景。这就像多个地点的场景，你们。花了半天时间。什么？是的。在剧本里，我们确实拍摄了这个，它在删除的场景里，安吉拉·马丁走到树前。它是她身高的两倍，她不得不把它拖过办公室。
Lady, I tripped over those pillows on the floor. Uh-huh. And the tree fell on my head.
What? I fell to the ground. The tree fell on top of me. Then I had to drag it down the stairwell.
this Christmas tree, out the building, through the parking lot, all the way to the street.
We filmed all of that.
It legitimately was a physical workout.
I actually, like, messed up my hair.
I had, like, scratches on, like, my hands from the tree trying to grip it.
None of it's in the episode.
女士，我被地板上的那些枕头绊倒了。嗯哼。树掉在了我的头上。什么？我摔倒在地上。树掉在了我身上。然后我不得不把它拖下楼梯。这棵圣诞树，出大楼，穿过停车场，一直到街上。我们拍摄了所有这些。这确实是一次体力锻炼。我实际上，像，弄乱了我的头发。我的手上因为树试图抓住它而有抓痕。没有一个在这一集里。
It's in the deleted scenes.
And what was great is over all of this action were two talking heads, one Angela and one Phyllis.
Can you play those?
I do not mind doing hard labor.
Ronald Reagan got his start as a stock boy lugging heavy boxes 10 hours a day.
Don't miss the pillow.
And he went on to become the president of a party planning committee.
I like to call the United States of America.
它在删除的场景里。最棒的是，所有这些动作之上是两个独白，一个是安吉拉，一个是菲利斯。你能播放那些吗？我不介意做苦力。罗纳德·里根作为仓库管理员每天搬运重箱子 10 个小时开始了。别错过枕头。然后他继续成为派对筹备委员会的主席。我喜欢称之为美利坚合众国。
Most people call it that.
Did you know that an ant can carry five times its own weight?
All it needs is a strong queen to tell it what to do.
And there's nothing that little creature can't accomplish.
Phyllis.
I know.
Phyllis and her power glasses and some serious sass.
Yes, that muffled sound in between was me like falling down the staircase with the Christmas tree.
大多数人这么称呼它。你知道蚂蚁可以携带五倍于自身重量的东西吗？它所需要的只是一个强大的女王告诉它该做什么。没有什么小生物是它无法完成的。菲利斯。我知道。菲利斯和她的权力眼镜以及一些严重的傲慢。是的，中间那个闷闷的声音是我像从楼梯上摔下来带着圣诞树。
Were you so bummed when you watched the episode and it was cut out?
I was so bummed because I thought it was hilarious.
And that talking head I do about Ronald Reagan, my hair is all messed up.
All right.
So Phil Shea has tackled a styrofey.
desk, chair, all objects wrapped in Christmas wrapping. He's also found Phyllis a pair of
power glasses. Phil Shea's next project would have been Princess Unicorn. Yes. Dwight enters with a
stack of boxes. And he explains that each year he researches the most popular toy of the holiday season.
当你看到这一集并且它被剪掉时，你很沮丧吗？我很沮丧，因为我觉得它太搞笑了。那个关于罗纳德·里根的独白，我的头发全乱了。好吧。所以菲尔·谢处理了一个泡沫塑料。桌子，椅子，所有物体都用圣诞包装包装。他还给菲利斯找了一副权力眼镜。菲尔·谢的下一个项目将是独角兽公主。是的。德怀特带着一堆盒子进来了。他解释说，每年他都会研究节日期间最受欢迎的玩具。
He buys as much of it as he can. And then as parents become more desperate, he sells them at a profit.
It's a little bit genius.
We got a lot of mail asking about this princess unicorn storyline.
Okay.
Where to begin?
First of all, this was a collaboration of several writers.
Justin said that they had originally written a different story for Dwight and at the last minute
they wanted to change it.
他尽可能多地买。然后当父母变得越来越绝望时，他以利润出售它们。这有点天才。我们收到了很多邮件询问这个独角兽公主的故事线。好的。从哪里开始？首先，这是几位编剧的合作。贾斯汀说他们最初为德怀特写了一个不同的故事，在最后一分钟他们想改变它。
And they had a new writer who had just started on the show that week named Halstead Sullivan.
This was his pitch.
Hallstead. Amazing.
Crushing it in his first week on the job.
We were able to get in touch with Halstead.
He confirmed, yes, that he pitched this idea of Dwight having a side hustle of buying up these holiday toys and selling them at a profit.
Halstead said that he and writer Aaron Scher were sent into a room to figure out what this toy should be.
Aaron said, well, kids love princesses and unicorns.
他们有一位新编剧，那周刚开始在节目中工作，名叫霍尔斯特德·沙利文。这是他的推销。霍尔斯特德。太棒了。在他工作的第一周就搞定了。我们能够联系到霍尔斯特德。他证实，是的，他提出了德怀特有一个副业，购买这些节日玩具并以利润出售的想法。霍尔斯特德说他和编剧亚伦·谢尔被派到一个房间里去弄清楚这个玩具应该是什么。亚伦说，嗯，孩子们喜欢公主和独角兽。
How about a princess unicorn doll?
I love this kind of collaboration.
So you have Halstead saying, we need the story of the toy and he sells the toys.
And then Aaron is like, what about if a unicorn and a doll collide?
Yes.
Then Halstead came up with the catchphrase, my horn can pierce the sky.
Hallstead, are you kidding me?
Right.
来一个独角兽公主娃娃怎么样？我喜欢这种合作。所以你有霍尔斯特德说，我们需要玩具的故事，他卖玩具。然后亚伦说，如果独角兽和娃娃碰撞会怎样？是的。然后霍尔斯特德想出了口号，“我的角可以刺破天空”。霍尔斯特德，你在开玩笑吗？对。
That was you?
That stuck in our heads forever.
Forever.
Do you remember that, Jenna?
Like we sing it all week.
We have to hear Michael sing it.
My horn can pierce the sky.
And then Jenna, when I listen to the DVD commentary, immediately Kate and I sang it.
那是你？那永远留在我们的脑海里。永远。你记得那个吗，珍娜？就像我们整周都在唱它。我们必须听迈克尔唱它。我的角可以刺破天空。然后珍娜，当我听 DVD 评论时，凯特和我立刻唱了它。
What?
My horn can pierce the sky.
Thank you, Halstead.
Well, you know, they made a whole commercial for this doll.
I know.
With a little girl and a jingle at the end.
It was crazy.
What else did they say about it?
什么？我的角可以刺破天空。谢谢你，霍尔斯特德。嗯，你知道，他们为这个娃娃制作了一个完整的广告。我知道。有一个小女孩和最后的叮当声。太疯狂了。他们还说了什么？
They said, actually, before settling on this idea, there was an all.
alternate idea called Hank Grenade.
And this was a doll that when you threw it, his arms blew off.
That was Hank Grenade.
But they settled on Princess Unicorn.
So once that was settled, there was a lot of discussion over what she should look like.
Was she a human princess with unicorn features?
Was she more of a horse with a human face?
他们说，实际上，在确定这个想法之前，有一个备选。备选想法叫“汉克手榴弹”。这是一个娃娃，当你扔它时，他的手臂会炸掉。那是汉克手榴弹。但他们选择了独角兽公主。所以一旦确定了，关于她应该长什么样有很多讨论。她是有人类特征的独角兽公主吗？她更像是一匹有人脸的马吗？
I guess they went around and around.
And in the end, Phil Shea had to make this princess unicorn doll.
Randy told me that Phil actually used a team of designers and toy makers.
Oh, my gosh.
And they had to come up with a design that would not infringe on anyone else's design because I guess toys in general and dolls specifically are very tightly controlled by the manufacturers.
Right.
Their intellectual property rights.
Yeah, it can't look like anything else.
我想他们绕来绕去，最后菲尔·谢不得不制作这个独角兽公主玩偶。兰迪告诉我，菲尔实际上动用了一个由设计师和玩具制造者组成的团队。天哪。他们必须想出一个不会侵犯他人设计的设计，因为我猜玩具，特别是玩偶，受到制造商的严格控制。没错。他们的知识产权。是的，它不能看起来像其他任何东西。
Yes.
And they actually had to go through the NBC Universal Legal Team to make sure that they had met all the requirements of a specifically unique doll toy.
That is how we came to have a princess unicorn.
Amazing.
Yeah.
Wow.
Phil Shea was so busy this episode.
So busy.
是的。他们实际上必须通过NBC环球法律团队，以确保他们满足了独特玩偶玩具的所有要求。这就是我们如何拥有独角兽公主的原因。太棒了。是的。哇。菲尔·谢这一集太忙了。太忙了。
Oh, my gosh.
When we would see him running through the parking lot, this is why.
I don't know how he did it.
I know.
Well, the party's underway now.
It's getting going.
There's cocktails.
Jim and Pam have this flirty moment with like he's rubbing the lamp for wishes.
天哪。当我们看到他在停车场跑来跑去时，原因就在这儿。我不知道他是怎么做到的。我知道。好吧，派对现在正在进行中。开始了。有鸡尾酒。吉姆和帕姆有一个调情的时刻，就像他在擦神灯许愿一样。
Well, this scene made me curious.
And I had also been watching the bloopers.
And there is this moment between Ed and John and the bloopers that never made it into the episode.
That's kind of weird where Jim is looking at this coffee mug that Andy made.
Okay.
I was like, what is the thing?
What are they, what are Jim and Pam doing?
So I was very curious about these scenes.
嗯，这一幕让我很好奇。我也一直在看花絮。在花絮里，埃德和约翰之间有一个从未出现在正片里的时刻。那有点奇怪，吉姆在看安迪做的那个咖啡杯。好吧。我在想，那是什么？他们在干什么，吉姆和帕姆在做什么？所以我对这些场景非常好奇。
And I went to the script.
And in the shooting draft, there is a Jim and Pam side.
by side talking head where they share that they are in a real financial bind. Oh. Yeah. And they have agreed
not to buy each other anything for Christmas, but instead we'll be taking items from the Dunder Mifflin office to give to
each other. Whoa. So yeah, there were all these little scenes of you guys like showing each other
different items around the office. And then there was a whole scene where you ultimately decided on something
and gave each other gifts. What did I get? I don't remember any of this. Wait, before I tell you,
you got. Can I just tell you some of the moments in the side-by-side talking head that I couldn't believe.
我看了剧本。在拍摄草稿中，有一个吉姆和帕姆并排的访谈，他们分享说他们陷入了真正的经济困境。哦。是的。他们已经商定圣诞节互不买礼物，而是从邓德·米夫林办公室拿东西送给对方。哇。所以，是的，你们有很多小场景，比如向对方展示办公室里的不同物品。然后还有一整场戏，你们最终决定了某样东西并互赠了礼物。我得到了什么？我不记得这些了。等等，在我告诉你之前，你得到了。我能先告诉你一些我在那个并排访谈里看到的让我难以置信的时刻吗？
All right. Jim shares that money's tight because of the closing fees on the house that he bought.
Okay.
Pam shares. Get ready. Pam says, my credit's so bad, I'm hoping someone steals my identity.
They couldn't handle my finances worse than me. Oh, no. Okay. Oops. Yeah. And Jim says,
it's okay. We've decided not to spend any money on presents this year. The rule is the gift
has to be something from inside the office.
Okay.
And Pam says, so in addition to the party, we're going to spend the day shopping.
好吧。吉姆分享说因为他买房的过户费，手头很紧。好吧。帕姆分享说。准备好了。帕姆说，我的信用太差了，我希望有人偷走我的身份。他们处理我的财务状况不会比我更糟了。哦，不。好吧。哎呀。是的。吉姆说，没关系。我们决定今年不在礼物上花钱。规则是礼物必须是办公室里的东西。好吧。帕姆说，所以除了派对，我们要花一天时间购物。
And if anyone's interested, my social security number is 793-47-6882.
Isn't that hilarious?
Yes.
What is Pam running up her credit on?
I don't know.
I know.
What is Pam buying?
Maybe she charged all of art school.
如果有人感兴趣，我的社保号码是793-47-6882。这不搞笑吗？是的。帕姆在透支什么信用？我不知道。我知道。帕姆在买什么？也许她把艺术学校的学费都刷卡了。
Just put it all on her card.
Maybe she did.
Well, do you want to hear what they gave each other?
Yeah.
What did I get?
After a whole party of them looking at items in the office.
Okay.
To, I guess, steal?
全都记在她的卡上。也许她真的这么做了。好吧，你想听听他们送给对方什么吗？是的。我得到了什么？在他们看了一整天办公室里的物品之后。好吧。去，我猜，偷？
I don't know.
What is their life of crime together?
All right.
At the end of the day, Pam hands Jim a gift wrapped in copier paper, and he opens it up,
and it's a pair of sunglasses that she has made out of paper clips and brown plastic from a folder.
Wow.
So wait, Phil Shea had to make that, too.
Yes.
我不知道。他们一起的犯罪生活是什么样的？好吧。一天结束时，帕姆递给吉姆一个用复印纸包装的礼物，他打开一看，是一副她用回形针和文件夹里的棕色塑料做的太阳镜。哇。等等，菲尔·谢也得做那个？是的。
He had to make sunglasses made out of paper clips.
And brown plastic.
And Jim's like sunglasses.
And they even have little pads for my nose.
They had little erasers where the nose would go.
I have to stop you.
Is this in the deleted scenes?
Can you screen grab these sunglasses and put them on the pod?
他得做一副用回形针和棕色塑料做的太阳镜。吉姆说，太阳镜。它们甚至还有我的鼻垫。它们有小橡皮擦在鼻梁的位置。我得打断你。这是在删减片段里吗？你能截屏这些太阳镜并把它们发到播客上吗？
No, it's not.
Oh, that's a tragedy.
I know, I know.
Because you know they exist somewhere.
Pam says it took me hours to make them.
Wow.
But don't use them outside.
because there's no UV protection.
不，不是。哦，那真是个悲剧。我知道，我知道。因为你知道它们存在于某个地方。帕姆说我花了好几个小时才做好。哇。但别在外面用它们，因为没有防紫外线功能。
Okay.
And then Jim hands her a box and she opens it to reveal a beautiful dainty watch.
And she's like, wait, you didn't make this.
You bought it.
No fair.
And Jim says, okay, here's the thing.
Technically, I had this in the office.
I bought it for you three years ago, but it was way too big and I chickened out.
好吧。然后吉姆递给她一个盒子，她打开一看，是一块漂亮精致的手表。她说，等等，你没做这个。你买了它。不公平。吉姆说，好吧，是这样的。严格来说，我把它放在办公室里。我三年前为你买的，但它太大了，我退缩了。
And Pam says, yeah, it kind of screams, I love you.
And Jim's like, do you like it?
And she says, I love it.
Wait, was that the year you gave me rocks?
Jim says, wishing rocks, also romantic.
Oh my gosh, I love this.
So you and John had this whole storyline that was playing out in the background that ended in the scene and it didn't make it in.
Do you want to hear something crazy?
帕姆说，是的，它有点在大喊，我爱你。吉姆说，你喜欢吗？她说，我爱它。等等，那是你送我石头的那一年吗？吉姆说，许愿石，也很浪漫。天哪，我喜欢这个。所以你和约翰有一整条在背景中展开的故事线，最后以这一幕结束，但它没能进入正片。你想听点疯狂的事吗？
While I was prepping Moroccan Christmas, I was cleaning out my desk.
At home?
At home.
And I found...
The teapot note.
Oh, good Lord.
Are you kidding?
I found it.
当我在准备《摩洛哥圣诞节》时，我在清理我的办公桌。在家里？在家里。我发现了……茶壶纸条。哦，天哪。你在开玩笑吗？我找到了它。
The actual note.
The note that John gave me at the end.
Oh, my gosh.
And the envelope says Pam, and it's a little Christmas card.
It was in with, like, all of my, like, stationary and stuff, right?
I'm, like, going through my stationary, and I'm like, what's this?
What's this card that says Pam?
I opened it up, and I was like, it's the teapot note.
真正的纸条。约翰最后给我的那张纸条。天哪。信封上写着帕姆，这是一张小圣诞卡。它和我所有的信纸之类的东西放在一起，对吧？我在翻我的信纸，我在想，这是什么？这张写着帕姆的卡片是什么？我打开它，我在想，这是茶壶纸条。
I love that that's what you found.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah, it is crazy, but you know what's so perfect is when I cleaned out my desk, if you remember Jenna, I found, this was like years ago, I found Dwight and Angela's like sex contract punch card.
Oh boy, our characters had different stories, didn't they?
Okay, all right. So I had to share that because I thought that was a wonderful Jim Pam thing that didn't get to be in the episode.
But now we really need to talk about these drinks that Michael is making for Meredith.
The first drink Michael makes Meredith, he calls it a one of everything.
It's equal parts, scotch, absent, rum, gin, vermouth, triple sec, and two packs of Splenda.
我喜欢你发现的是这个。这不疯狂吗？是的，这很疯狂，但你知道什么最完美吗？当我清理办公桌时，如果你还记得的话，珍娜，我发现了，那是几年前的事了，我发现了德怀特和安吉拉的性契约打孔卡。哦，天哪，我们的角色有不同的故事，不是吗？好吧，好吧。所以我必须分享这个，因为我觉得那是一个美妙的吉姆和帕姆的事情，没能出现在剧集中。但现在我们真的需要谈谈迈克尔为梅雷迪思调制的这些饮料。迈克尔为梅雷迪思调制的第一个饮料，他称之为“什么都来一点”。它是等量的苏格兰威士忌、苦艾酒、朗姆酒、金酒、味美思、橙皮利口酒和两包代糖。
Now, isn't some of this drink a Long Island iced tea minus the Splenda?
I don't know.
Am I wrong?
I don't know what's in Long Island iced tea.
I just know it's like seven liquors.
Yeah.
Well, yeah.
Well, Meredith thinks this is the best thing she's ever had in her life.
现在，这种饮料里难道没有长岛冰茶吗，减去代糖？我不知道。我错了吗？我不知道长岛冰茶里有什么。我只知道它像是有七种烈酒。是的。嗯，是的。好吧，梅雷迪思认为这是她一生中喝过的最好的东西。
Oh, yeah.
Then Michael makes Jim a drink with vodka and orange juice.
Not a screwdriver, guys.
It's called a orange vodka juice.
Yeah.
It rolls off the tongue.
It does.
There was an alt in the script.
哦，是的。然后迈克尔给吉姆调了一杯伏特加加橙汁。不是螺丝起子，伙计们。它叫“橙子伏特加汁”。是的。朗朗上口。确实。剧本里有一个备选方案。
Okay.
In the script, Michael makes Jim a drink with Jack Daniels and just regular Coca-Cola.
And he calls it a Coke Daniels.
Kate shared that in one scene with Steve, they were improvising.
Okay, Steve was making up all these drinks.
And Steve improvised sangria with peppermint schnops.
And Kate improvised, let's call it sex on the couch.
And Steve as Michael was like, ew.
好吧。在剧本里，迈克尔给吉姆调了一杯杰克丹尼加普通可口可乐。他称之为“可乐丹尼”。凯特分享说在和史蒂夫的一场戏里，他们在即兴发挥。好吧，史蒂夫在编造所有这些饮料。史蒂夫即兴发挥了薄荷杜松子酒桑格利亚汽酒。凯特即兴发挥说，我们叫它“沙发上的性爱”。史蒂夫作为迈克尔说，呃。
But that didn't make it in.
And then Kate also shared, are you ready for this?
He hands her a drink in one take.
She takes a big swig and goes, oh, my God, you guys, there's real booze in that.
They had forgotten to empty out one of the bottles because they would empty out the
liquor bottles and put just water or iced tea. Yeah. And they had missed one. And they gave Kate a drink
with actual booze in it. She was like, guys, that's booze. Oh, no. I mean, she only took one
swig. You know what I mean? But still. What a shocker. I know. Also during this setup of the party,
但这没能进入正片。然后凯特还分享说，准备好了吗？他在一条拍摄中递给她一杯饮料。她喝了一大口，说，哦，天哪，伙计们，里面有真正的酒。他们忘了倒掉其中一个瓶子，因为他们通常会倒掉烈酒瓶，只放水或冰茶。是的。他们漏掉了一个。他们给了凯特一杯真的有酒的饮料。她说，伙计们，那是酒。哦，不。我是说，她只喝了一口。你知道我的意思吗？但还是。真是个震惊。我知道。在派对设置期间，
I want to point out, this episode had a lot of shots that were just like little moments, right? It really
reminded me of some of our early episodes where we had these, what did we used to call those?
Just these little vignettes in the background. Yeah. These little moments that the B camera would get
that really filled in the whole picture. It really reminds me of the first two seasons. Same.
Well, during this kind of montage of filling out the party and what's going on,
you know, Ed, as Andy is playing the sitar. Yes. We got a lot of mail about it.
Izzy T, Liam D, and Grant S all wrote in to ask,
Does Ed Helms really play the sitar?
我想指出，这一集有很多镜头只是小瞬间，对吧？它真的让我想起了我们早期的一些剧集，我们过去称那些为什么？只是背景中的这些小片段。是的。B摄像机捕捉到的这些小瞬间，真正填补了整个画面。它真的让我想起了前两季。一样。好吧，在填补派对和正在发生的事情的蒙太奇中，你知道，埃德饰演的安迪在弹西塔琴。是的。我们收到了很多关于它的邮件。Izzy T、Liam D和Grant S都写信问，埃德·赫尔姆斯真的会弹西塔琴吗？
No.
Not before this episode, he didn't.
But he's such a badass that he just picked it right up.
Yeah.
So you guys probably know that Ed plays guitar, he plays banjo.
Randy told me that previously in his career, he had produced a different show where
they needed an actor to play a song on the sitar.
And this actor was also a guitar player, but he was told that the sitar,
不。在这一集之前，他不会。但他是个狠角色，他直接就学会了。是的。所以你们可能知道埃德会弹吉他，他会弹班卓琴。兰迪告诉我，在他职业生涯的早期，他制作过另一个节目，他们需要一个演员在西塔琴上弹奏一首歌。这个演员也是个吉他手，但他被告知西塔琴，
is a very difficult instrument to play.
It's very difficult to tune properly.
And that in that instance, on that other show, he had to hire a tutor and allow about four
weeks of practice so that this actor could credibly pull off the bit.
So, because the script had Ed playing all these different songs with only a couple
weeks notice, he asked Phil Shea to rent a sitar.
He went to Ed.
He said, I'll get you a tutor.
是一种非常难弹的乐器。很难调准音。在那次节目中，他不得不雇一个导师，并留出大约四周的练习时间，以便这个演员能可信地完成这个片段。所以，因为剧本要求埃德在只有几周通知的情况下弹奏所有这些不同的歌曲，他让菲尔·谢租了一把西塔琴。他去找埃德。他说，我会给你找个导师。
Yeah.
But Ed said, I'll figure it out.
And Randy was like, okay.
Ed's like, I play the banjo.
I'm going to flex a little bit.
A little bit.
I got this.
And Ed totally, totally did it.
是的。但埃德说，我会搞定的。兰迪说，好吧。埃德说，我会弹班卓琴。我要炫耀一下。一点点。我能行。埃德完全，完全做到了。
He just picked it up and played it.
Yes.
I have a little catch where Ed slipped up.
What?
So you guys listening, my family and my close friends, they call me Ange.
It's my nickname and my family.
And it's like what my husband calls me and my husband calls me.
My mom, you know, everyone calls me Ange.
他直接拿起来就弹了。是的。我有一个小发现，埃德说漏嘴了。什么？所以你们在听，我的家人和亲密朋友，他们叫我Ange。这是我的昵称，在我的家里。这是我丈夫叫我的，我丈夫叫我。我妈妈，你知道，每个人都叫我Ange。
Well, Ed called me Ange, right?
In real life.
Yeah.
He never called me Angela.
And right when he starts playing the sitar at four minutes, 21 seconds, tell me what you hear.
Hey, hey, Hans, check it out.
There's a place in France where the naked ladies dance.
Oh, wow.
好吧，埃德叫我Ange，对吧？在现实生活中。是的。他从来没叫过我安吉拉。就在他开始弹西塔琴的4分21秒时，告诉我你听到了什么。嘿，嘿，Hans，看看这个。法国有个地方，裸体女士在跳舞。哦，哇。
He called me Ange.
Not Angela.
And Angela Martin would have never let Andy call her ang.
Anyone call her ang.
No.
She's using the formal version of her name only.
Only.
For sure.
他叫我Ange。不是安吉拉。安吉拉·马丁永远不会让安迪叫她Ang。任何人叫她Ang。不。她只使用她名字的正式版本。只有。肯定的。
Only Dwight can call her monkey.
Everyone else calls her Angela.
In that moment, to me, Ed just sort of slipped and just was like, hey, Angie.
He was probably like concentrating on his playing.
Yeah.
Right?
He was in musician mode.
Yeah.
只有德怀特能叫她猴子。其他人叫她安吉拉。在那一刻，对我来说，埃德只是有点说漏嘴了，就像是，嘿，Angie。他可能是在专注于他的演奏。是的。对吧？他处于音乐家模式。是的。
That just warmed my heart when I heard it.
I just had to share.
Well, next up is quite a scene.
Meredith is dancing up a storm in the conference room, and she sets her hair on fire.
Yes.
Dwight has to rush in and put it out with a fire extinguisher.
Oh, lady.
Talk about mail.
当我听到它时，那真的温暖了我的心。我只是不得不分享。好吧，接下来是一个相当精彩的场景。梅雷迪思在会议室里跳得正欢，她把头发点着了。是的。德怀特不得不冲进去用灭火器扑灭它。哦，女士。说到邮件。
People need to know.
How did they pull off this stunt where her hair catches on fire?
Was it Kate?
Was it a stunt double?
We have a lot to share with you, because this is one of the biggest stunts I think we ever did in the bullpen.
For sure. A person was on fire.
Yeah.
All right. Well, I got some of the info from Randy.
人们需要知道。他们是怎么完成这个头发着火的特技的？是凯特吗？是替身吗？我们有很多要和你们分享，因为我认为这是我们在办公区做过的最大的特技之一。肯定的。一个人着火了。是的。好吧，我从兰迪那里得到了一些信息。
And I got info from Kate. So let's break it down.
First of all, we did use a stunt double for Kate. Her name was Marie Fink.
Mm-hmm.
Our stunt coordinator that day was Scott Aleva, and he had to, like, do a bunch of prep for this.
He had to, like, send a whole plan into NBC Universal Safety Department explaining how exactly we would do this safely.
We had safety officers on set.
We had a special effects crew on set.
And we had the LA Fire Department on set.
我从凯特那里得到了信息。所以让我们分解一下。首先，我们确实为凯特使用了特技替身。她的名字叫玛丽·芬克。嗯哼。我们那天的特技协调员是斯科特·阿莱瓦，他不得不做很多准备工作。他不得不把整个计划发送给NBC环球安全部门，解释我们究竟将如何安全地做到这一点。我们在片场有安全官员。我们在片场有特效团队。我们在片场有洛杉矶消防局。
Kate said there were so many people from the fire department there.
They like took up a whole wall.
I believe it.
Yeah.
What a crazy day of work for them.
I know.
Now, Paul Fieg specifically staged this scene so that Meredith was dancing alone in the conference room.
And this was done to make it safer.
凯特说消防局来了很多人。他们几乎占满了一整面墙。我相信。是的。对他们来说真是疯狂的一天工作。我知道。现在，保罗·费格专门安排了这一幕，让梅雷迪思独自在会议室里跳舞。这样做是为了更安全。
Yes.
And they dressed the stunt double Marie in this full fireproof body suit.
It's called like a Nomex.
And she wore like a headstocking that was flameproof.
And then she put on Kate's wardrobe.
I guess these Nomex suits are what race car drivers wear when they're racing, you know, in case their car burst into flames.
Then Kim Ferry had to create a bunch of wigs.
Yes.
是的。他们给特技替身玛丽穿上了这套全防火连体衣。它叫Nomex。她戴着防火的头套。然后她穿上了凯特的戏服。我猜这些Nomex套装是赛车手在比赛时穿的，你知道，以防他们的车起火。然后金·费里不得不制作了一堆假发。是的。
And Kate shared about these wigs, you guys.
Kate said, Angie, they were natural hair.
Mm-hmm.
And then they actually burned the wigs with fire.
And she said, I had to wear the stinkiest wig the whole rest of the week because, you know, when you burn hair, you know the smell.
Oh, I know it well.
I mean, once you've smelled that, it's like burned into your brain.
凯特分享了这些假发，伙计们。凯特说，Angie，它们是真发。嗯哼。然后他们实际上用火烧了假发。嗯哼。她说，我整个星期剩下的时间都得戴着那顶最臭的假发，因为，你知道，当你烧头发时，你知道那种味道。哦，我很清楚。我是说，一旦你闻过那个，它就像烧进了你的大脑。
Yes.
So Kate had to wear the stinky wig the rest of the week.
Oh.
Well, I guess to pull off this stunt, they put this flam.
amiable gel all over Marie's body and her hair.
And then she used one of the actual real candles in the conference room to set her hair on fire.
I guess they did have a stunt double dressed as Dwight.
His name was Sean Crowder.
是的。所以凯特整个星期剩下的时间都得戴着那顶臭假发。哦。好吧，我猜为了完成这个特技，他们在玛丽的身体和头发上涂满了这种易燃凝胶。然后她用了会议室里的一根真正的蜡烛把她的头发点着了。我猜他们确实有一个打扮成德怀特的特技替身。他的名字叫肖恩·克劳德。
But in the end, it was actually Rain.
Rain ran in and put out the stunt double with an actual fire extinguisher.
I know.
No pressure, Rain.
Right?
But Kate said he did it.
And then Kate said for continuity, they had to take Marie out.
And Kate stepped back in with the burnt wig, right?
但最后，实际上是雷恩。雷恩跑进来，用真正的灭火器扑灭了特技替身。我知道。没有压力，雷恩。对吧？但凯特说他做到了。然后凯特说为了连贯性，他们不得不把玛丽带走。凯特戴着烧焦的假发重新上场，对吧？
The smelly burnt wig.
The smelly burnt wig kind of assumed the same position Marie was in.
And then Rain had to spray Kate with the real fire extinguisher.
So Kate got hosed as well.
Justin told me that we did it all in one take.
I'm so glad for everyone's sake.
Yeah.
I'm so glad.
那顶臭烘烘的烧焦假发。那顶臭烘烘的烧焦假发摆出了和玛丽一样的姿势。然后雷恩不得不喷射凯特，用真正的灭火器。所以凯特也被喷了。贾斯汀告诉我我们一次就拍完了。我为每个人感到高兴。是的。我很高兴。
Also, look at Kate's dancing.
This is like lunging forward and back and forward and back.
And I'm like, Kate, were you sore?
My gosh, that's like a physical day.
Randy told me that Kate and Marie got together and planned out the dance moves.
So that Marie could look exactly like Kate and her movements, yes.
Which is amazing to me because it looks like completely spontaneous dancing,
but they really planned it so that it would coordinate.
还有，看看凯特的舞蹈。这就像前后猛冲，前后猛冲。我在想，凯特，你酸痛吗？天哪，那真是体力活的一天。兰迪告诉我，凯特和玛丽聚在一起计划了舞蹈动作。这样玛丽的动作就能看起来和凯特一模一样，是的。这对我来说很神奇，因为它看起来像是完全自发的舞蹈，但她们确实计划好了，以便协调。
So they were doing the same thing.
Yes.
And if you watch the episode, it's very,
rare that only one person is in the conference room at a party, but that was for everyone's safety,
like you said.
Yeah.
So Kate said it was kind of, you know, odd to be in there alone for all those takes, like a fishbowl.
But I really related because there's a whole scene coming up where you guys are all together
所以她们在做同样的事情。是的。如果你看这一集，在派对上会议室里只有一个人是非常罕见的，但那是为了每个人的安全，就像你说的。是的。所以凯特说，在那儿独自待着拍那些镜头有点奇怪，就像个鱼缸。但我真的很有共鸣，因为接下来有一整场戏，你们都在一起
on the floor and I'm in the kitchen.
I know.
For the whole episode.
Lady, I think we should take a little break and then we'll come back and make you go to the kitchen.
Make me go to the kitchen.
And Michael is going to share with us about a responsibilitini.
Oh, I can't wait.
在地板上，而我在厨房里。我知道。整整一集。我知道。女士，我想我们应该休息一下，然后回来让你去厨房。让我去厨房。迈克尔要和我们分享关于“责任马提尼”的事。哦，我等不及了。
It's a deleted scene.
I can't wait to share.
So we are back.
Oscar?
You have a little bit of granola on your boob.
Oh, thanks for telling me.
We ate a granola bar during the break.
You're eating it off your shirt?
这是一个删减片段。我等不及要分享了。所以我们回来了。奥斯卡？你的胸口有一点燕麦棒。哦，谢谢你告诉我。我们在休息时吃了一根燕麦棒。你从衬衫上把它吃掉？
What else would I do?
If I pick it off, I have to, what, throw it on the floor?
No, put it in the trash.
Well, you would fit in.
I was still hungry.
You'd fit in very well with my boys.
Listen, we're friends here.
I've seen them eat things off their clothing, too.
我还能做什么？如果我把它捡起来，我得，什么，把它扔在地板上？不，把它扔进垃圾桶。好吧，你会很合群的。我还是很饿。你会和我的男孩们很合得来。听着，我们是朋友。我也见过他们从衣服上吃东西。
Oh, my God.
Listen, every once in a while.
You're going to lick a piece of granola bar off your shirt.
You know what else I'm going to do sometimes?
Sometimes the salad dressing is so good.
I lick the plate.
Okay, I'm here for licking the plate,
but you just ate a piece of granola off your t-shirt.
哦，天哪。听着，偶尔。你会从衬衫上舔掉一块燕麦棒。你知道我有时还会做什么吗？有时沙拉酱太好吃了。我舔盘子。好吧，我支持舔盘子，但你刚才从T恤上吃了一块燕麦。
You lifted your shirt up towards you so you could eat that tiny piece of granola.
Because I'm a classy lady.
You are classy. And you know what? You do not waste. And that I respect. Thank you. Okay. As I was saying,
Oscar, Jim, Michael and Stanley try to set a date for something. We don't know what they're talking about.
They're trying to agree on a time to do something. Nothing's working. We do learn that Michael goes to the dentist every month.
Well, because of his soft teeth. Every month. We established that in dinner party.
I feel like he talks their ear off.
I feel like there's like a dental hygienist that he just talks their ear off.
你把衬衫往上拉向自己，这样你就能吃掉那一小块燕麦。因为我是个优雅的女士。你很优雅。而且你知道吗？你不浪费。这一点我很尊重。谢谢。好吧。正如我所说，奥斯卡、吉姆、迈克尔和斯坦利试图为某事定个日期。我们不知道他们在谈论什么。他们试图商定一个时间去做某事。什么都不行。我们确实了解到迈克尔每个月都去看牙医。嗯，因为他的牙齿很软。每个月。我们在《晚宴》那一集里确定了这一点。我觉得他把他们的耳朵都磨出茧子了。我觉得有个牙科保健员，他只是把他们的耳朵都磨出茧子了。
What do you do for soft teeth?
You know what?
I'm going to ask my dentist the next time I'm there.
He's a fan of the show.
He's also a breadmaker.
And he gave me his sourdough discard.
And it is fantastic sourdough discard.
Wow.
你对软牙齿做什么？你知道吗？下次我去的时候我要问问我的牙医。他是这个节目的粉丝。他也是个面包师。他给了我他的酸种废料。那是很棒的酸种废料。哇。
Great dentist.
Okay.
Great baker.
I'm going to ask him about soft teeth.
Stay tuned.
Baker and a dentist.
Listen, they also can't do it on a.
Groundhog Day because Michael, he celebrates privately. Some fans asked Justin in an interview once,
伟大的牙医。好吧。伟大的面包师。我要问他关于软牙齿的事。敬请期待。面包师兼牙医。听着，他们也不能在土拨鼠日做，因为迈克尔，他私下庆祝。有些粉丝曾经在采访中问贾斯汀，
what is it that Michael's doing? And he said, I imagine he just watches Groundhog Day all day,
the movie. He watches the movie. And I also think he watches to see if Punksitone, is it Punksitone?
Phil? Phil. Yeah. I think he watches to see if Phil sees his shadow. I think he watches the whole
broadcast. It's a big event. Maybe he goes. He's busy. That's what we know. Yeah.
In the end, they decide today is the day and what they're planning is an intervention.
Christmas Eve, office party, intervention.
Listen, if I had to explain what an intervention is, it's like a surprise party for people who have addictions.
And what you do is you make them feel badly about themselves so they stop.
迈克尔在做什么？他说，我想他只是整天看《土拨鼠日》，那部电影。他看电影。而且我也认为他看是为了看Punxsutawney，是Punxsutawney吗？菲尔？菲尔。是的。我想他看是为了看菲尔是否看到了自己的影子。我想他看了整个广播。这是一个大事件。也许他去了。他很忙。这就是我们所知道的。是的。最后，他们决定今天就是日子，他们计划的是一次干预。平安夜，办公室派对，干预。听着，如果我必须解释什么是干预，它就像是为有瘾的人举办的惊喜派对。你所做的是让他们对自己感觉不好，这样他们就会停止。
Michael Scott, right there, guys.
Her Michael Scott.
That was the talking head that made it into the show.
here is an alt that got deleted and it cracked me up.
We're going to call this Responsibilitini, guys.
It takes a lot of courage to admit you are right.
And talking about my strengths has always been one of my strengths.
And I am right.
迈克尔·斯科特，就在那儿，伙计们。她的迈克尔·斯科特。那是进入剧集的访谈。这里有一个被删掉的备选方案，它让我笑死了。我们称之为“责任马提尼”，伙计们。承认你是对的需要很大的勇气。谈论我的优势一直是我优势的一部分。我是对的。
Meredith needs help.
She needs help like an alcoholic needs a drink.
And she's about to get a big shot of Michael Scott, straight up on the rock.
with ice, no chaser.
I call it a responsibilityini,
shaken with lemon, twist a lime.
Okay, okay.
We've played a lot of talking heads that didn't make it.
梅雷迪思需要帮助。她需要帮助，就像酒鬼需要酒一样。她即将得到一大杯迈克尔·斯科特，纯饮，加冰，不加水。我称之为“责任马提尼”，加柠檬摇匀，加青柠扭转。好吧，好吧。我们播放了很多没能进入正片的访谈。
Uh-huh.
A lot of scenes that didn't make it in the show.
This is the biggest tragedy.
A responsibility.
Everything about that was gold.
I could listen to it five times.
I know.
嗯哼。很多没能进入剧集的场景。嗯哼。这是最大的悲剧。责任马提尼。关于它的一切都是金子。我可以听五遍。我知道。
I was like, I have to play it.
is gold. That was like on the level of Dwight's whole speech about stealing the ball from Tiffany's
and going to all the countries and all that. Oh my God. It was so good. You're going to get a big shot
of Michael Scott. Oh. Shaken, not stirred. Responsibilitini. That's incredible. Well, we're all
going to circle up on the floor now. Not Angela, though. Phyllis has other plans for you.
It involves a hairnet.
Mm-hmm.
Lots of fanning. Got to fan some pitas, got to toast them on both sides, got to fan napkins.
我在想，我必须播放它。是金子。那就像德怀特关于从蒂芙尼偷球并去所有国家等等的整场演讲一样。哦，天哪。太棒了。你会得到一大杯迈克尔·斯科特。哦。摇匀，不要搅拌。责任马提尼。那太不可思议了。好吧，我们现在都要在地板上围成一圈。不过不是安吉拉。菲利斯对你有别的计划。它涉及到一个发网。嗯哼。大量的扇风。得扇一些皮塔饼，得把它们两面烤一下，得扇餐巾纸。
Yeah. And off to the kitchen I go. Meanwhile, the rest of us sit on the floor and engage in a real uncomfortable intervention of Meredith.
I don't know how you guys got through the scene without laughing. I remember two things happening during this week. One, I was bummed because I was in the kitchen by myself. And I had to enter in during the scene. So it's not like I had to be there.
Do you remember this? Because Justin reminded me of this, and I had forgotten it, which was that Paul Feig insisted on shooting the entire intervention scene from top to bottom without cutting and every take was about eight minutes long. Yes. So I would be in the kitchen with a magazine. I actually, on the DVD commentary, I said I brought a magazine back there eventually because I was back there so long. And then they would cue me and then I would walk in.
then I'd have to go back.
So crazy.
I remember my legs fell asleep.
It's very hard to sit on the floor in a pencil skirt and panty hose.
是的。然后我就去厨房了。与此同时，我们其余的人坐在地板上，进行了一场真正不舒服的梅雷迪思干预。我不知道你们是怎么在不笑的情况下完成这一幕的。我记得这一周发生了两件事。第一，我很沮丧，因为我一个人在厨房里。我不得不在场景中进入。所以并不是我必须在那儿。你记得这个吗？因为贾斯汀提醒了我这一点，而我忘了，那就是保罗·费格坚持从头到尾拍摄整个干预场景而不剪辑，每一条大约八分钟长。是的。所以我会在厨房里拿着一本杂志。实际上，在DVD评论中，我说我最终带了一本杂志到后面，因为我在后面待了太久。然后他们会给我提示，然后我会走进去。然后我得回去。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。我记得我的腿麻了。穿着铅笔裙和连裤袜坐在地板上非常困难。
Well, you had to do an odd cross.
You had to do that one foot under the other.
And at nine minutes, 46 seconds, there's a real good Pam panty hose catch.
Oh, yeah.
I can see your panty hose.
I don't doubt it.
You have panty hose toes.
I remember trying to figure out because, you know, once you pick the way you're
嗯，你必须做一个奇怪的交叉。你必须把一只脚放在另一只脚下。在9分46秒时，有一个非常好的帕姆连裤袜镜头。哦，是的。我能看到你的连裤袜。我不怀疑。你有连裤袜脚趾。我记得试图弄清楚，因为，你知道，一旦你选择了你的方式
sitting, you have to sit like that. You can't shift and move or change your position.
Because it has to match you guys. So however you sit, that's it. So Mindy laying on her stomach like that,
which I was so jealous. Which I took a picture of. I was jealous at first, but then you know her back
started to ache. It had to because that's like doing a, what is that, the cow? No, it's not a cow.
It's a yoga thing. Oh yeah. What's that yoga pose called?
Were you, we are, the cobra, cobra. I knew it. Not the cat. I don't know why. That was so
exciting, but I just recalling any information at my age just gets me real amped up. So she had to do
a mini cobra all day. You had to sit with the one foot under your butt, but one foot extended.
坐着，你必须那样坐。你不能移动或改变你的姿势。因为它必须和你匹配。所以无论你怎么坐，就是这样。所以敏迪像那样趴在肚子上，我非常嫉妒。我拍了一张照片。起初我很嫉妒，但后来你知道她的背开始疼了。它必须疼，因为那就像在做，那是什么，牛？不，那不是牛。那是瑜伽动作。哦，是的。那个瑜伽姿势叫什么？你是，我们是，眼镜蛇，眼镜蛇。我知道。不是猫。我不知道为什么。那太令人兴奋了，但我这个年纪回忆任何信息都会让我非常兴奋。所以她不得不整天做迷你眼镜蛇。你必须一只脚放在屁股下坐着，但另一只脚伸展。
Yep, I know. And I do remember that we went around. And, you know, I was mostly reactions.
I don't think I had any lines in this scene. It was very hard not to laugh. It was very hard not to laugh
when Creed says that he can get a fire permit in a couple hours. It was,
pretty amazing. We talked on the DVD commentary about Creed's outfit and what he's wearing in this
scene. He actually wore something similar to an award show. Do you remember? He wore the long,
white. I don't remember this. This is very much sort of his outfit as something Creed would actually
wear. And he looks fantastic. There is a delicious Andy talking head. I feel like we all knew this guy in
college, the guy that would chug a fifth of Soco. Uh-huh. Boot, rally. How many nicknames does he have,
是的，我知道。我确实记得我们绕了一圈。而且，你知道，我主要是反应。我想我在这一幕里没有任何台词。很难不笑。当克里德说他能在几个小时内拿到火灾许可证时，很难不笑。那，相当惊人。我们在DVD评论中谈到了克里德的服装以及他在这一幕中穿的东西。他实际上在颁奖典礼上穿过类似的东西。你记得吗？他穿了那件长的，白色的。我不记得这个了。这非常像是克里德实际上会穿的衣服。他看起来棒极了。有一个美味的安迪访谈。我觉得我们在大学里都认识这个家伙，那个会狂饮五分之一Soco的家伙。嗯哼。呕吐，集会。他有多少个昵称，
by the way. He's puke. He's ace and he's buzz. Did he get straight A's or straight B's? We're not sure.
He got straight B's. Yeah, but he aced everything. Yeah. Well, surprise, surprise, this intervention
does not result in Meredith deciding to go to rehab. Michael's clearly not qualified to do this,
and Toby's going to call it. He's like, you know what, we're going to stop this. I do have to point out one of my
favorite moments when Kevin offers his way that her drinking affected him.
He got to go to the movies.
By the way, thank you, he says.
Yeah.
顺便说一句。他是呕吐，他是王牌，他是嗡嗡。他拿的是全A还是全B？我们不确定。他拿的是全B。是的，但他把一切都搞定了。是的。好吧，惊喜，惊喜，这次干预并没有导致梅雷迪思决定去康复中心。迈克尔显然没有资格做这件事，托比要叫停了。他说，你知道吗，我们要停止这个。我确实必须指出我最喜欢的时刻之一，当凯文提供他的方式，她的饮酒如何影响了他。他可以去看电影。顺便说一句，谢谢，他说。是的。
Michael's like, you're not getting it.
But you're right.
Michael is not trained to do this, you know, a trained interventionist.
This is a job in real life.
People train for this.
Yeah.
Kate had a whole speech that was in the script as Meredith where she just addresses the group.
And she's like, listen, I'm bored.
迈克尔说，你没明白。但你是对的。迈克尔没有受过训练来做这件事，你知道，受过训练的干预者。这是现实生活中的一份工作。人们为此受训。是的。凯特有一整段演讲在剧本里，作为梅雷迪思，她只是向小组致辞。她说，听着，我很无聊。
you're boring she said to Michael and he goes hey and she was like you know what I drink because I'm bored
try to be more interesting and she's like who else is bored here and like everyone raises their hands
she like hijacks the meeting from Michael right and then she's like we all do things to cope so I drink
when I'm bored and then she goes around the room she goes you all have coping mechanisms you eat you eat
you shop you confuse Dwight and then she's like who confuses Dwight
She's me. No, me. Oh, okay. And then she like points at Stanley and she's like, you eat. And then Stanley has a talking head where he's like, I do eat when I'm bored. But I also drink. And I drink a lot more than Meredith. I just don't do it at work. And I keep my clothes on.
Oh my goodness. Yes. This scene was way bigger.
Oh, wow.
你很无聊，她对迈克尔说，他去，嘿，她说，你知道吗，我喝酒是因为我无聊，试着变得更有趣一点，她说，这里还有谁无聊，就像每个人都举手，她就像从迈克尔那里劫持了会议，对吧，然后她说，我们都做些事情来应对，所以我无聊时喝酒，然后她绕着房间走，她说，你们都有应对机制，你吃，你吃，你购物，你困惑德怀特，然后她说，谁困惑德怀特？是我。不，我。哦，好吧。然后她指着斯坦利说，你吃。然后斯坦利有一个访谈，他说，我确实在无聊时吃东西。但我也会喝酒。而且我喝得比梅雷迪思多得多。我只是不在工作时喝。而且我穿着衣服。哦，天哪。是的。这一幕大得多。哦，哇。
Michael is going to take Meredith into his office where they're going to talk for 45 minutes.
45 minutes. And in the meantime, Angela is going to plead with Phyllis. Please, can I stop cutting the pita? Do I really have to wear the hairnet? Have mercy. It's the season of mercy. Phyllis is no. No. I have a thing I want to point out at 13 minutes, 35 seconds. Phyllis is telling Stanley about the Moroccan food they're eating and Angel's eating this cookie. She spits it out.
Yeah.
We did a lot of takes of this.
I'm not sure why.
Okay.
But the cookie started to turn on me because I took a big bite.
迈克尔要带梅雷迪思进他的办公室，他们要在那里谈45分钟。45分钟。与此同时，安吉拉要恳求菲利斯。求求你，我能停止切皮塔饼吗？我真的必须戴发网吗？发发慈悲。这是慈悲的季节。菲利斯说不。不。我有一件事想在13分35秒指出。菲利斯在告诉斯坦利他们正在吃的摩洛哥食物，安吉拉在吃这个饼干。她把它吐了出来。是的。我们拍了很多条这个。我不确定为什么。好吧。但饼干开始让我反胃，因为我咬了一大口。好吧。
Mistake.
Okay.
Take a small bite, guys.
Always.
Because by the eighth take, the thought of that cookie makes you want to barf.
Right.
It doesn't matter what it is.
错误。好吧。咬一小口，伙计们。总是。总是。因为到第八条时，想到那个饼干就让你想吐。对吧。不管它是什么。
It doesn't matter if it's your favorite dessert.
Mm-mm.
And it started to turn on me.
And so I took some peanuts and I stuck them in my hand.
And when they would cut to me eating, I would like just put a bunch of the peanuts in my mouth and hold the cookie.
I was trying to do a faky eat.
Mm, faky eat.
Finky eat.
不管它是不是你最喜欢的甜点。嗯-嗯。它开始让我反胃。所以我拿了一些花生，把它们塞进手里。当他们切到我吃的时候，我会像往嘴里塞一把花生，拿着饼干。我试图做一个假吃。嗯，假吃。假吃。
And then I would spit out peanuts instead of the cookie.
Okay.
So what we see on camera, that is chewed up peanuts?
We don't know.
We don't know which take they used.
Was it early?
Was it late?
然后我会吐出花生而不是饼干。好吧。所以我们在镜头上看到的，那是嚼碎的花生？我们不知道。我们不知道他们用了哪一条。我们不知道他们用了哪一条。是早期的？还是晚期的？
I don't know.
These are the things you try to do at work.
How do I not eat that cookie?
Well, when Michael leaves his office with Meredith, they're going somewhere.
He says, I'll meet you in the parking lot. And then he asks Toby for the number of that rehabilitation center. And everyone's like, wow, he did it. And then, you know, he finishes writing the number down and he throws the pen at Toby's head. And hits him in the forehead. We got a fan question about that. Well, we have stories about it, too.
Kelsey B would like to know, was the pen throwing scripted or improvised?
It was scripted.
And Justin said that Steve had a special rubber pen.
我不知道。这些是你试图在工作中做的事情。我怎么才能不吃那个饼干？好吧，当迈克尔带着梅雷迪思离开他的办公室时，他们要去某个地方。他说，我在停车场见你。然后他向托比要那个康复中心的号码。每个人都说，哇，他做到了。然后，你知道，他写完号码，把笔扔向托比的头。击中了他的前额。我们收到了一个关于那个的粉丝问题。好吧，我们也有关于它的故事。凯尔西B想知道，扔笔是剧本写的还是即兴的？是剧本写的。贾斯汀说史蒂夫有一支特殊的橡胶笔。
And I remember it because it was in the pen cup on Pam's desk.
There were real pens and then one faky pen.
And I was sitting there and I kept positioning the pen so that Steve could pick up.
up the faky pen. This would have been another thing Phil Shea would have had to have gotten for the
episode. Faky rubber pen so that he could throw it at Toby's head. They inserted that little
thump sound later. We did about four or five takes of it, I guess. You guys, if you rewatch this,
you will notice behind Michael, there are no people. We're all standing way off to the right.
Yep. You want to know why? Because we couldn't stop laughing. So when they would cut to Michael,
我记得它，因为它在帕姆桌上的笔筒里。有真正的笔，然后有一支假笔。我坐在那里，我一直摆放那支笔，以便史蒂夫能拿起假笔。这本来是菲尔·谢必须为这一集准备的另一件事。假橡胶笔，这样他就能把它扔向托比的头。他们后来插入了那个小小的砰声。我想我们拍了大约四五条。你们，如果你重看这个，你会注意到迈克尔身后没有人。我们都站在右边很远的地方。是的。你想知道为什么吗？因为我们无法停止笑。所以当他们切到迈克尔时，
after throwing it, we'd be behind him giggling.
So they pushed us all to the right.
And they had to get our reaction take like a whole beat later
when we had gotten our composure.
Paul also couldn't stop laughing.
I know.
Every time that little rubber pen thumped him in the forehead,
he would break.
扔完之后，我们会在他身后咯咯笑。所以他们把我们都推到了右边。他们不得不等我们冷静下来后，再拍我们的反应镜头。保罗也无法停止笑。我知道。每次那支小橡胶笔砰地击中他的前额，他就会破功。
I know.
And there is such a fun blooper
where Paul decided to prank Steve
during this scene.
We have to listen to it.
You know, could you write down the name of their...
Rehabilitation clinic you mentioned.
Wow.
我知道。有一个非常有趣的花絮，保罗决定在这一幕中恶作剧史蒂夫。我们必须听听。你知道，你能写下他们的名字吗……你提到的康复诊所。哇。
Impressed.
That's pretty.
What does I even say?
You go,
you?
What did he do?
Instead of writing down a fake phone number,
he wrote,
印象深刻。那很漂亮。我甚至说了什么？你去，你？他做了什么？他没有写下假电话号码，而是写了，
you.
And so Steve, in the scene,
glances down and it says,
fuck you. And he started laughing
and he couldn't even throw the pen because he was
laughing too hard. That is so funny.
Well, have you know,
Faky Pen lived in the pen cup
你。所以史蒂夫，在场景中，向下瞥了一眼，上面写着，去你的。他开始笑，他甚至不能扔笔，因为他笑得太厉害了。那太搞笑了。好吧，你知道，假笔住在笔筒里
for weeks after we shot the scene
and people were always coming over
trying to grab a pen to use
and they would get faky rubber pen.
And I never got rid of it because it just was
funny to me. It was funny to me
that people would grab faky pen.
So now Meredith and Michael are in the car.
在我们拍摄完这一幕后的几周里，人们总是过来试图抓一支笔来用，他们会拿到假橡胶笔。我从来没有扔掉它，因为它对我来说很有趣。人们会抓假笔，这对我来说很有趣。所以现在梅雷迪思和迈克尔在车里。
This is going to start such a fantastic sequence between Meredith and Michael.
Both Steve and Kate just knock it out of the park.
They're driving.
Meredith thinks they're going to a bar.
She's listing off all these bars.
And Kate Flannery said in real life, she kept trying to slip her family's bar in there.
Because you know, her family owned a bar in Philadelphia called Flannery's.
Yep.
这将开启梅雷迪思和迈克尔之间如此精彩的序列。史蒂夫和凯特都表现得非常出色。他们在开车。梅雷迪思以为他们要去酒吧。她在列举所有这些酒吧。凯特·弗兰纳里说在现实生活中，她一直试图把她家人的酒吧塞进去。因为你知道，她家人在费城拥有一家叫弗兰纳里的酒吧。是的。
But it didn't make it in.
But all the other bars, she says, are local scrant.
in bars. They're real places. Yeah, well, that was part of the reasons why Flanneries wouldn't have
checked out, right? But she also wanted you guys to know that Steve did his own driving. They're not being
pulled. Yeah, you can kind of tell. Yeah, he's driving and doing all the dialogue because there were those
little lipstick cameras. And then they had, I think, a truck in front of them with a camera rigged on the
back to get them through the windshield. Well, when they finally arrive at their destination,
it is revealed that they are at Sunrise Rehab. Meredith gets super pissed.
但它没能进入正片。但她说所有其他酒吧都是当地斯克兰顿的酒吧。它们是真实的地方。是的，好吧，这就是为什么弗兰纳里酒吧没能入选的部分原因，对吧？但她也想让你们知道史蒂夫是自己开的车。他们没有被拖着。是的，你可以看出来。是的，他在开车并进行所有的对话，因为有那些小口红摄像机。然后我想，他们前面有一辆卡车，后面装有摄像机，以便通过挡风玻璃拍摄他们。好吧，当他们最终到达目的地时，发现他们在日出康复中心。梅雷迪思超级生气。
So pissed. So pissed. Now, Kate told me they had stunt people there for her and Steve. Should it get too physical that they could have this choreograph thing with the stunt people? And her and Steve were like, no, we're going to go for it. Kate was like, Steve, let's do it. And they did not use the stunt people. Everything you see is actually Kate and Steve, just freaking going for it.
I think I notice one moment. We cut out of it really quickly. When Meredith throws the trash can down and it looks like Michael trips and falls, I feel like I see Kate start to check on Steve.
Oh, yeah? Like maybe like, oh, are you okay? Like just the littlest moment and we cut out of it and then they, you know, they have a bigger chase around the parking lot.
Well, Kate said that's faky trash.
Faky trash. That was faky trash. So whatever Steve fell on wasn't real trash.
So Phil Shea also had to make faky trash.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
太生气了。太生气了。现在，凯特告诉我他们为她和史蒂夫准备了特技演员。如果变得太激烈，他们可以用特技演员来编排动作。她和史蒂夫说，不，我们要亲自上。凯特说，史蒂夫，我们来吧。他们没有使用特技演员。你看到的一切实际上都是凯特和史蒂夫，只是疯狂地去做了。我想我注意到了一个时刻。我们很快就切出了。当梅雷迪思把垃圾桶扔下，看起来迈克尔绊倒了，我觉得我看到凯特开始检查史蒂夫。哦，是吗？就像，哦，你还好吗？就像最小的时刻，我们切出了它，然后他们，你知道，他们在停车场有更大的追逐。好吧，凯特说那是假垃圾。假垃圾。那是假垃圾。所以史蒂夫摔倒的任何东西都不是真正的垃圾。所以菲尔·谢也得做假垃圾。是的。天哪。
This man's week was insane.
Yes.
This scene was scripted at the top where she doesn't want to get out of the car, but they immediately
then just went off.
Yeah.
You know, because Paul Feig just wanted them to really go for it, not worry about the lines.
And that whole sequence where Meredith is saying, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute,
that's not in the script.
这个男人这一周真是太疯狂了。是的。这一幕在开头是有剧本的，她不想下车，但他们随后立刻就即兴发挥了。是的。你知道，因为保罗·费格只是想让他们真正投入进去，不用担心台词。梅雷迪斯说“等一下，等一下，等一下”的那整段戏，剧本里根本没有。
I loved it.
It was so real.
I thought Kate did such a great job.
Well, this whole thing ends with Michael dragging Meredith into the rehab center.
And we should tell you, the intake nurse was played by our very own first assistant director, Kelly Cantley.
Yes. She also helps escort them out.
Yeah, at the end, when Michael discovers that you can't force people to go to rehab.
我太喜欢了。太真实了。真的太真实了。我觉得凯特的表现非常棒。嗯，整件事以迈克尔把梅雷迪斯拖进康复中心告终。我们应该告诉你们，那个接待护士是由我们自己的第一助理导演凯莉·坎特利扮演的。是的。她还在最后帮他们护送出来。是的，在最后，当迈克尔发现你不能强迫别人去康复中心的时候。
Yep. And now, awkward car ride back.
But you know what Michael's going to do?
Michael's had a realization. He realizes that, you know, in order to get help, a person has to hit their rock bottom.
So he's going to make it his mission to help Meredith reach her rock bottom. Oh, my gosh. And he thinks he can do it because he did it with Jan.
Oh, my gosh. Like an amazing line. There's still going to be quite a bit of drama back at the office.
Oh, yes. We start with Toby. Oh, Toby, man. He thinks he's going to get to be the hero.
to his little girl.
He is going to score one of the princess unicorn dolls from Dwight for his daughter.
没错。现在，尴尬的车程回程开始了。但你知道迈克尔要做什么吗？迈克尔有了一个顿悟。他意识到，你知道，为了获得帮助，一个人必须跌入谷底。所以他要把帮助梅雷迪斯跌入谷底作为他的使命。天哪。他认为他能做到，因为他以前对简就是这么做的。天哪。真是绝妙的台词。办公室里还会有不少戏剧性的事情发生。哦，是的。我们从托比开始。哦，托比，伙计。他以为他能成为他小女儿心目中的英雄。他要从德怀特那里为女儿抢到一个公主独角兽玩偶。
But Dwight has sold them all out.
He just sold his last one to Daryl.
Yes.
All right.
I just unsolicited get this email from Jen Salada.
About this scene?
About this scene and this episode.
I guess the writers like Justin and Halstead and Aaron, they were all texting each other about this
但德怀特已经把它们全卖光了。他刚刚把最后一个卖给了达里尔。是的。好吧。我刚刚收到珍·萨拉达发来的不请自来的邮件。关于这一幕？关于这一幕和这一集。我想编剧们，比如贾斯汀、霍尔斯特德和亚伦，他们都在互相发短信讨论这个
storyline.
And somehow Jen got involved.
This email pops in my inbox yesterday.
She's like, Jenna, we've all been texting about the princess unicorn.
Because you asked Justin about it.
Yeah.
Okay.
And she was like, I have a story and I asked Paul if I could share it.
故事情节。不知怎么的，珍也参与进来了。这封邮件昨天出现在我的收件箱里。她说：“珍娜，我们都在发短信讨论公主独角兽的事。因为你问了贾斯汀关于它的事。”是的。好吧。她说她有一个故事，她问保罗她能不能分享。
Okay.
And I was like, oh, I'm so intrigued.
She made an audio clip.
Here it is.
Oh, my gosh.
There was a moment that happened behind the scenes of Moroccan Christmas where Paul and I were
working on a script together.
I'm not sure if it was the fifth season finale or.
好吧。我说，哦，我太感兴趣了。她制作了一个音频片段。就在这儿。天哪。在《摩洛哥圣诞节》的幕后发生过一件事，当时保罗和我正在一起写剧本。我不确定那是第五季大结局还是
what, but we were kind of under the gun, I remember, when we were writing, and he had to go down on set
and shoot a scene as Toby. And then when he came back up, we needed to push forward on the script.
And I remember that he was sitting on the couch and he was like, oh, I think I just screwed up
that scene that I shot. And I was like, I probably didn't. I'm sure you didn't. You're being hard
on yourself. He's like, no, no, I really think I screwed it up. And he's kind of stuck on it and
wasn't very typical of him. So I was like, tell me what happened. And he said, well, I was supposed to be
upset and sad because I wanted this princess unicorn doll for my daughter and Daryl wanted the doll for
his daughter. And I needed to be really sad. And so I thought of what, you know, Steve might do or what
什么，但我们当时时间很紧，我记得，我们在写剧本的时候，他必须下到片场去拍一场托比的戏。当他回来时，我们需要推进剧本。我记得他坐在沙发上说：“哦，我想我刚才拍的那场戏搞砸了。”我说：“可能没有。我相信你没有。你对自己太苛刻了。”他说：“不，不，我真的觉得我搞砸了。”他一直纠结于此，这对他来说很不典型。所以我说：“告诉我发生了什么。”他说：“嗯，我本该感到沮丧和难过，因为我想要这个公主独角兽玩偶给我女儿，而达里尔想要这个玩偶给他女儿。我需要表现得非常难过。所以我想到了一些，你知道，史蒂夫可能会做的事情，或者
I thought Jenna might do, which is think of something sad that happened in, in real life to them and
something that like triggered these sad feelings and sad emotions and kind of be in that place and
use it for the scene. And I said, well, it sounds smart. Like how to go? And he said, well, I didn't do
that. And I asked him why. And he said, well, I thought about getting sad, but it didn't seem
worth it. And I remember laughing at that, being like, I'm pretty sure you just made the decision
not to act. I think that's what just happened in that moment.
But I remember watching that scene later and thinking it was such a perfectly Toby choice.
It was a great scene.
我想珍娜可能会做的事情，那就是想一些在现实生活中发生在他们身上的悲伤的事情，一些能触发这些悲伤感觉和情绪的事情，让自己处于那种状态，并将其用于表演。我说：“听起来很聪明。进展如何？”他说：“嗯，我没那么做。”我问他为什么。他说：“嗯，我想过要让自己难过，但觉得不值得。”我记得当时笑了，觉得：“我敢肯定你刚才做出了不演戏的决定。”我想那一刻发生的就是这样。但我记得后来看到那场戏时，觉得那是一个非常完美的托比式的选择。那是一场很棒的戏。
And I feel like when you're Toby and you're going about the world and Michael's always making you feel put upon and all of this stuff, you can't constantly keep getting sad.
So it ended up being a very, very wonderful choice that I think he made.
But in the moment, I think he pretty much decided he wasn't.
going to act because he didn't want to be sad that day. And I'll never forget that. I loved it.
Jen was so excited to tell me this story. She was like, I have to give him grief. And I guess they
talked together and they were laughing about it. And Paul was like, yeah, you can share. You can share
that it's true. I don't want to be sad. I don't want to dig too deep and actually cry in this scene
because then I'm going to be sad all day. I'm going to be thinking about whatever precipitated it.
我觉得当你作为托比，在世界上行走，而迈克尔总是让你感到被压迫，所有这些事情，你不能一直让自己难过。所以这最终成了一个非常、非常美妙的选择，我认为是他做出的。但在那一刻，我想他基本上决定他不会去演，因为他那天不想难过。我永远不会忘记这一点。我太喜欢了。珍非常兴奋地告诉我这个故事。她说：“我必须去损他。”我想他们在一起谈论时都在笑。保罗说：“是的，你可以分享。你可以分享这是真的。我不想难过。我不想挖掘得太深，在这场戏里真的哭出来，因为那样我一整天都会很难过。我会一直想着是什么引发了这一切。”
I love that Jen just wanted to give Paul shit on our podcast.
I know.
She was just like, email hits my inbox.
Oh, so funny.
I agree, though, when I watched the scene, like, I didn't think anything of it.
I was like, oh, that's perfect.
Yeah.
Oh, so funny.
我喜欢珍只是想在我们的播客上损保罗这一点。我知道。她就像是，邮件发到了我的收件箱。哦，太搞笑了。不过我同意，当我看到那一幕时，我没多想。我心想，哦，那太完美了。是的。哦，太搞笑了。
And I guess she would, like, give him Shataki about that for years to come.
Gosh, speaking of sad.
Should we talk about the saddest scene ever?
Saddest scene ever.
it all starts because Angela is done. She is done with Phyllis. Well, Phyllis tells her to go get the tree and bring it back.
I know. Phyllis and I absolutely loved this episode. We got to do so much together, even more than you even see in the actual episode. I can't tell you how amazing it felt as Angela Martin to turn to her and say, shut up. It felt so good. And I was really proud.
proud of this scene. I thought Phyllis and I really had this perfect chemistry in this moment.
And then she tells everyone and she shames Angela Martin in front of the whole bullpen.
我想她会在未来的几年里一直拿这件事损他。天哪，说到悲伤。我们应该谈谈有史以来最悲伤的一幕吗？有史以来最悲伤的一幕。这一切的开始是因为安吉拉受够了。她受够了菲利斯。嗯，菲利斯让她去拿树并带回来。我知道。菲利斯和我绝对喜欢这一集。我们一起做了很多事，甚至比你在实际剧集中看到的还要多。我无法告诉你，作为安吉拉·马丁，转过身对她说“闭嘴”的感觉有多棒。感觉太好了。我真的很为这一幕感到自豪。我觉得菲利斯和我在那一刻真的有完美的化学反应。然后她告诉了所有人，并在整个办公室员工面前羞辱了安吉拉·马丁。
And when she did, I was so in the moment with her, I felt the heat of my skin. Like my face started
to flush. Yeah. You can see it. Everyone is looking at you. Everyone. You know, and we've talked about
whenever you had a scene where the whole bullpen focused on you, you were already heightened a little bit, like your nerves.
And I really just, oh, man, I was, as the character, I felt like I couldn't get out of there fast enough.
And then Andy walks in.
I know.
And the way Ed, just, you know, Ed Helms, the person, his inherent goodness and sweetheart just carries.
through the character of Andy.
当她这样做时，我完全沉浸在和她的对手戏中，我感觉到了皮肤的热度。就像我的脸开始发烫。是的。你可以看出来。每个人都在看着你。每个人。你知道，我们谈过，每当你有一场整个办公室都聚焦于你的戏时，你已经有点紧张了。我真的，哦，伙计，作为角色，我觉得我恨不得立刻逃离那里。然后安迪走了进来。我知道。而艾德，你知道，艾德·赫尔姆斯本人，他内在的善良和甜美，通过安迪这个角色表现了出来。
I know. Well, here's the thing.
Is Andy, like, completely annoying?
Sure.
Mm-hmm.
But he's also got this boyish charm.
Yeah.
A boyish enthusiasm, right?
Yes.
我知道。嗯，问题是这样的。安迪，他完全烦人吗？当然。嗯。但他也有这种男孩般的魅力。是的。一种男孩般的热情，对吧？是的。
For singing this song to you.
Yes.
And in the script, the song he sings is Silent Night.
Oh, yes.
Mm-hmm.
Randy said, the morning of the shoot, they told Ed,
he was so scared to say it. He said they've changed their mind. Can you do deck the halls?
Ed had to learn a whole new song to play on the sitar. He had just learned Silent Night.
为你唱这首歌。是的。在剧本里，他唱的歌是《平安夜》。哦，是的。嗯。兰迪说，拍摄当天早上，他们告诉艾德，他当时害怕得不敢说。他说他们改变主意了。你能唱《装饰大厅》吗？艾德不得不学习一首全新的歌在西塔琴上演奏。他刚刚学会了《平安夜》。
Yes, he'd had that thing for a couple weeks and he'd been fiddling around on it. And then they were like, can you do deck the halls?
Randy told me it took him about a minute and a half to figure it out because he's amazing.
He's a musical genius. They thought it would be funny, the juxtaposition of this sort of very cringy moment for a
Andy to be playing this upbeat song.
And you know, he improvised the Ridded It to Do at the end.
I know.
So good.
We're all just staring at him.
是的，他拿到那个东西已经几周了，一直在上面拨弄。然后他们说，你能唱《装饰大厅》吗？兰迪告诉我，他花了一分半钟就搞定了，因为他太棒了。他是个音乐天才。他们认为这会很有趣，这种安迪演奏这首欢快歌曲的尴尬时刻的并置。你知道，他在最后即兴发挥了“Riddit-dit-do”。我知道。太棒了。我们都只是盯着他看。
And Ed played the moment so perfectly.
My heart completely broke for Andy.
I felt so bad for him.
And I started to cry.
Like actually crying?
Yeah.
I actually cry.
If you look at this, it pushes in on my face.
艾德把那一刻演得太完美了。我的心完全为安迪碎了。我为他感到难过。我开始哭。是真哭吗？是的。我真的哭了。如果你看这一幕，镜头推向了我的脸。
And I'm completely tearing up.
Those are those moments as an actor where you have so inhabited your character's story and the story of the people around you where your body, like you didn't even have to make yourself cry or think of something sad. You were just so in the moment that the emotions just flood.
No, really, really. And everyone was playing it so real.
Paul Fieg told us to. Like he said when we come around with that B camera and this was similar to his director.
in Office Olympics. He said, I don't want you to comment on it with, you know, no kind of funny
looks or anything. Like, this is like truly a human moment. And just stand there. Just be in it.
Mm-hmm. It was great direction. And you felt it. Yeah. You felt heavy. It felt really heavy.
And I felt horrible. And I started to cry. You know, in rewatching it all, I just thought this
我完全泪流满面。作为演员，那些时刻是你已经完全融入了角色的故事以及周围人的故事，你的身体，你甚至不需要强迫自己哭或想一些悲伤的事情。你只是完全沉浸在那个时刻，情绪就涌出来了。不，真的，真的。每个人都演得那么真实。保罗·费格告诉我们要这样。就像他说当我们用B摄像机绕过来时，这和他在《办公室奥运会》中的导演风格类似。他说：“我不想让你用任何评论，你知道，没有任何滑稽的表情之类的。这就像是一个真正的人性时刻。就站在那里。就沉浸在其中。”嗯。那是很棒的指导。你感觉到了。是的。你感觉很沉重。感觉真的很沉重。我感觉糟透了，我开始哭。你知道，在重温这一切时，我只是觉得这一集
episode was written and directed and acted so, so well. I was really proud of us as a show.
You know what, Angela, this was what Paul Figue could do for us, you know, like he was really good
at directing us to allow these moments to breathe. And you're so good in this. Oh, thanks, lady.
You're so good in this whole episode and this moment at the end. It is more powerful because it's real.
Yeah.
You really nailed it.
Thanks so much, lady.
Thank you.
写得、导得、演得都太好了。我真的很为我们这部剧感到自豪。你知道吗，安吉拉，这就是保罗·费格能为我们做的事，你知道，他真的很擅长指导我们让这些时刻有呼吸的空间。你在这一集里演得太好了。哦，谢谢，女士。你在整集和最后这一刻都演得太好了。它更具感染力，因为它很真实。是的。你真的演活了。太感谢了，女士。谢谢。
And I thought Kate Flannery crushed this episode, too.
Same.
And you know, guys, the supporting cast, these moments were fewer and far between for us.
And so when they happened, we just treasured it.
And it was so fun to rewatch it.
And you guys would get these scripts with no notice, and you'd have to just step up to the plate and suddenly carry an episode.
And you always did it because we had a really great.
bench on our show. We got a deep bench, y'all. We did. Well, that is Moroccan Christmas. We did it. We did it. We all hope
我觉得凯特·弗兰纳里在这一集里也表现得非常出色。我也是。而且你们知道，伙计们，对于配角来说，这些时刻对我们来说是少之又少的。所以当它们发生时，我们只是珍惜它。重温这一集太有趣了。你们会毫无预兆地拿到这些剧本，你们必须挺身而出，突然承担起一整集。你们总是能做到，因为我们的剧组有非常棒的替补阵容。我们有深厚的替补阵容，伙计们。我们确实有。好吧，这就是《摩洛哥圣诞节》。我们做到了。我们做到了。我们都希望
you'll have a little responsibility in your life. Yeah, and just want to give a few thank yous to Justin Spitzer,
Aaron Schor, Halstead Sullivan, Jen Salada, Randy Cordray, and Stephen Sox. Remember, you can find Stephen
and his wife, Lori, on their podcast if we knew then. And I know you traded a bunch of messages with Kate as
Yes, Kate Flannery and James Carey, because the script having the shooting draft was just amazing for this one.
And before we go, one little tidbit, we're so excited to finally get to share with you.
Yes.
We're so excited to tell you guys that we have partnered with Comedy Central and Cartooner Radio to bring you animated clips of our podcast.
你们的生活中能有一点责任感。是的，只想对贾斯汀·斯皮策、亚伦·肖尔、霍尔斯特德·沙利文、珍·萨拉达、兰迪·科德雷和斯蒂芬·索克斯表示感谢。记住，你们可以在他们的播客《如果我们早知道》中找到斯蒂芬和他的妻子洛里。我知道你和凯特交换了很多信息，因为有拍摄草稿的剧本对这一集来说真是太棒了。在离开之前，有一个小花絮，我们非常兴奋终于能和你们分享。是的。我们非常兴奋地告诉你们，我们已经与喜剧中心和Cartooner Radio合作，为我们的播客制作动画片段。是的。
You know, we're constantly getting mail from people saying they wish they could watch us on video.
And for many reasons we won't get into now, we do not videotape our podcasts, but Cartooner Radio has taken some of the audio and they have animated it, which in my opinion is even better than watching a video.
It is, you guys. They are so creative. Jenna and I are now a cartoon. I love it. I love it.
And they have picked these funny moments to animate. It's going to debut on Comedy Central's YouTube. We'll put it in our social so you can find it.
We can't wait for you to see it.
It starts tomorrow.
Woo-hoo!
All right, guys, we will see you next week.
你知道，我们经常收到人们的来信，说他们希望能在视频中看到我们。由于我们现在不便详述的许多原因，我们没有录制播客的视频，但Cartooner Radio截取了一些音频并将其制作成了动画，在我看来，这比看视频还要好。确实是这样，伙计们。他们太有创意了。珍娜和我现在成了卡通人物。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。他们挑选了这些有趣的时刻来制作动画。它将在喜剧中心的YouTube频道首播。我们会把它放在我们的社交媒体上，这样你们就能找到它。我们迫不及待想让你们看到。明天就开始。呜呼！好了，伙计们，我们下周见。
Your horn can pierce the sky.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent.
Our audio engineer is Sam Peel.
Kiefer, Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
你的号角可以刺破天空。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的“第二杯”剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·皮尔。基弗，Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。